this is jocko podcast number 307 with
echo charles and me jocko william good
evening echo good evening also joining
us again tonight is dave burke at
evening dave good evening
[Music]
i
gave everyone fair warning that this
book was going to take a while we are
going to continue the review of on the
psychology of military incompetence
which we started on podcast 303
304 305 306.
now we're on 307 so if you haven't
listened to those go back and do so if
you listen to those you probably
realized that which i realized i haven't
pointed out yet
i hope it's obvious even though the
context of these books is military
it doesn't just apply to the military it
applies to everyone in every leadership
situation
which is why we can learn so much from
these insights with that let's get
well let's get back to the book yes as
they like to say on the psychology of
military incompetence by dr
norman f dixon also
world war ii vet wounded in action legit
guy
a little bit too crazy on the
psychology stuff sometimes especially
nowadays the psychology some of the
psychology freud's been debunked freud
was a cocaine addict
freud was freud was was uh what's it
prescribing cocaine for like every
problem that you had
you know you said i'm not feeling very
well cocaine oh you know i'm sick to my
stomach cocaine
i'm not getting along with my wife
cocaine this guy was doing cocaine and
prescribing cocaine
and apparently he lied about a bunch of
stuff too he would say that he cured
people that never got cured or the or he
he would say that they were cured but
they were really just cocaine addicts
so
there is some stuff
and and
i don't know
the i never was a big psychology guy
until
we had jordan peterson on this podcast
that was kind of the first time i said
oh i get it
that's where i realize these guys are
brain mechanics that understand there's
a problem they look at it they go yep
we've seen this before
yep i know this pattern oh you're scared
of this thing or you don't get along
with these types of people or whatever
they say yup we've seen that before
here's how we can actually fix it
i
prior to that thought psychology was
what's the right word kind of
you know uh gobbledygook is that the
right word yeah what would you just say
yeah a little bit of woo-woo stuff a
little bit
like hey how could these guys what are
they gonna do whisper in your ear you
know i kind of i thought it was that
kind of thing i didn't realize that they
had methodologies and that they made
sense what about hypnosis or whatever i
don't really understand hypnosis too
much
i've never been hypnotized i've never
even been to one of those shows where
people get hypnotized and they act like
a monkey or whatever yeah yeah have you
been to one of those yeah you believe it
i believe that hypnosis can work on some
people in fact i think that that's
that's the case yeah yeah but the show
that i went to the i went to two of them
that i remember and i remember thinking
this hypnotist isn't that good either
not that good or the person the subject
or whatever was just sort of going along
okay not because they were in on some
scam but more than just down for the
cost down for the car exactly right they
didn't want to make everything look dumb
and stuff so they just did it have you
ever seen anyone get hypnotized no have
you ever been hypnotized
no
well they you there's little tests they
can do to you like that that's like i
saw that on rogan yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it sounds about rolling your eyes
back or something like that who's that
guy
i don't know i forget
so that's kind i sort of you know how
you kind of looked at it
not really 100 sure that's kind of how i
looked at psychology before before
uh jordan came on and i was i i
understood
and what was weird was how he was
explaining exposure therapy which is
exactly what's in way the warrior kid
and i said oh this stuff can make sense
got it but of course there's some weird
stuff there's still weird stuff in
psychology and they're doing weird stuff
right now in the psychological
world
the way they're coming out with all
kinds of weird things so
did you study psychology or did you take
any psychological i'm sure i took
something actually i'm not sure i did
but i don't remember if i did i don't
remember it
other than maybe what whatever you
learned in high school yeah maybe that's
what made me think it was a woo-woo yeah
that's the term you used
and what did i say gobbledygobling
[Music]
the psychologists out there i apologize
it's not gobbledygook and it's not
woo-woo it's legit it's mind
mechanics well okay you ever heard of uh
pavlov's dog yes okay so just that alone
so that's legit yeah like just that
don't think about it like freaking
you just associate a bell with food and
it's like your body responds like you're
be hit like stuff that you typically
don't control just responds in that way
it's like oh okay so you just think
about how deep that goes yep and then
people who understand that and can
navigate and guide and kind of influence
in that way yeah yeah that makes sense
and so here's the deal on the in this
book i didn't want to just start trying
to play
psychological historian right and going
back and but there's definitely some
things i read i was like okay bro
you know
hey dr nixon i respect you but
i'm not gonna i'm
it's too much
right it's too much a lot of that
freudian stuff is too much
it's weird
not just weird it's not it's not that
it's just weird if it's weird but it
makes but it's but it's backed up cool
there's some weird stuff going on in
your head
but when you read something you go that
seems kind of weird
and then you find out that it's all
debunked anyways
and that was the deal with freud freud
like i said on the last podcast
a broken clock is war is right twice a
day well that's the same thing with
freud he was right about some stuff the
biggest thing being that you do have
underlying
psychological thoughts
subliminal thoughts or subconscious
thoughts not subliminal sub subconscious
thoughts that drive your decision making
it make you act a certain way
so if you got whatever your parents
treated you a certain way you're gonna
tend to wave you know if your parents
built distrust in you you might not
trust people as much if they wanted you
to win all the time you might and that
could go two ways right you could be
like oh i'm going to win or i don't give
a [__] yeah right so it's weird how
you're going to turn out but the what is
you can't predict how the person is
going to turn out but you can say it has
to do with the fact that
every time little johnny
didn't win first place his dad was
beating him he either grows up and is
winning yeah or he just doesn't care
about competing right he's not even
competing
but those are under a lot there's an
underlying cause now what freud did was
he brought it all down to like
how you were potty trained
and just
no
bro it's not just that
so
that being said
there are underlying things and this guy
ends up profiling all these different
people so here we go we're gonna get
into this uh this section is called
character and honor kind of
it opens up with a great quote
why should a man be in love with his
fetters
though of gold
so you you are chained
and you're in love with those chains
but you shouldn't be even if they're
made of gold you shouldn't be in love
with them
and another one moderation in war
is imbecility
interesting
uh go into the book here
in the context of militarism the forces
of conscious
and of character manifest themselves in
various guises in medieval notions of
chivalry in codes of honor such as the
duel and in the belief that officers
must of necessity be gentlemen
as carl demet demeter showed has shown
in his history of the german officer
corps these notions of honor and
chivalry brought about
and were themselves reinforced by a care
to select officer material from the
aristocracy and rural land owners a
state of affairs reflected in the
contrast of snobbiness
exclusiveness sense of honor and lack of
intellectual ability which obtained
between the officer corps corps drawn
from the aristocratic junker families of
the great estates of prussia and those
more bourgeois elements from the
industrialized southwest of germany
so these old military officers came from
rich folk
and he said there's a difference between
some of the rich folk that were in the
city and some of the rich folk that were
big landowners and they had a little bit
different behavior not gonna spend too
much time on that but i'm gonna fast
forward a little bit a coat of be a code
of honor is a set of rules for behavior
the rules are observed because
to break them provokes the distressing
emotions of guilt or shame whereas guilt
is a product of knowing that one is
transgressed and therefore might be
found out shame results from actually
being found out in military circles
traditionally the greater crime
it is usually assumed that military
codes of honor
serve to reduce fear
this may well be so their primary object
however is to combat not so much fear
as the sort of behavior to which fear
might otherwise give rise in other words
they are designed to ensure that
threatening situations are met by fight
rather than flight
they do this by making the social
consequences of fight
the social consequences of flight rather
more unpleasant than the physical
consequences of fight that's freaking
radical right
like i would rather and you hear teen
guys say this all the time i'd rather
just freaking die
than be a [__]
100 percent i've heard effect as a
matter of fact uh
btf tony said that on this podcast he
was scared shitless of heights and he's
on some
80-story building in
hong kong or singapore or something and
he's got to repel off of it and he's
totally thinking he's going to die and
he's like well i would rather die
than be a [__] up here so their their
their
their rules work
whereas the latter might lead to
physical pain mutilation and death the
former eventuates with far greater
certainty in in personal guilt and
public shame
what i'm thinking about this is
i'm sitting here thinking like who
fought who said well you know what we
need to do is we need to create a code
of honors that we can make sure that
people don't run away that would be some
really meticulous
like preemptive
ideas
i'm thinking that there is a tribal
nature to this stuff like we are
instinctively
programmed
that if you run
you're not looking out for your clan and
you suck and we don't like you
i think that's i think there's an
instinct to that not just a code that's
written by modern man
but i think there's like a code that's
instilled in us
by being an animal yeah
that seems like the case for sure
maybe the code is just to like
take that in an extreme situation
and animals have it too like a pack of
hyenas go after a lion or whatever they
go after animals that can definitely
kill a couple of them
but they'd rather be the one that gets
killed then be the one that runs away
and they know that if they can't run if
they run away they're not going to
survive as a species so they got to get
it on oh yeah
man i watched some hyenas the other day
discovery channel type
more like youtube freaking red zone like
nine videos deep or whatever
but dude this zebra was getting eaten by
hyenas
and first of all the hyenas were savage
hyenas are my favorite land animal by
the way that's interesting yeah but the
zebra was stoic he was having his legs
eaten and he looked the look on his face
was he was watching an afternoon movie
yeah yeah i've seen that too
i wonder if there's like a thing that
triggers on on a prey animal that like
because you see that a lot it's not like
you don't see
well i don't know if i've ever seen any
zebra syndrome animal like screaming and
stuff oh no i have you have yeah i
always see like the deer just sort of
stoic
there's there's ones where those things
are just screaming and not handling it
yeah i think there's stoic zebras and
there's unstoppables that's what i think
all right
uh he's got a little indent here a
little section
when a soldier in action sees his life
in immediate danger even the bravest
will be seized by a moment of fear
biologically speaking fear is a natural
reflex sensation of the instinct of
self-preservation which dwells within
every man heroes included
again what's a little bit interesting
about that is like dean ladd being on
this podcast going into tarawa
and uh hey dean were you scared he's
like no
that was going to happen to someone else
so maybe even the hyenas think it's
going to happen to someone else
that paw ain't going to hit me right
right we're not going to catch a
freaking canine tooth to the jugular on
this one
if victory is to be one the the
elementary physical sensation must
somehow be artificially suppressed
overcompensated by a contrary reflex of
the psychic and moral kind converted
into action
bro i'm a little bit in disagreement
here because i i've seen guys that
you're just like well this guy doesn't
care he doesn't think he can die
whatever walking or walking across the
street running across the street
totally going against
i don't think there's enough time
to think hmm i want to go drag that guy
out of the street but it looks really
dangerous but
i want to prove myself no they're like
hey i'm gonna go get that guy because
he's hurt
what do you think dave
yeah i mean i'm thinking about all this
like even the need to write this stuff
down
all this stuff pragmatically makes sense
but i've observed people do things in
environments that sort of defy some of
the things that are being said so to
bare minimum there's there's definitely
exceptions to this idea that all men
have this thing
and
if they don't all have it some of them
go through whatever that process is in
light speed you know if it's if it's
still happening and i can't see it it's
happening so quickly that they're just
on doing things
i have seen
i have seen people do things
that are dumb and be like hey bro
you need to get put your head down i
mean i i i
from a basic self-preservation like
sniper fire is a good example we would
take sniper fire pretty regularly
and
i've seen guys get so frustrated and so
fed up and i saw a platoon commander
once behaved just like incorrectly
walking around on the rooftop like no
this isn't
moving past the fear this is uh some
other disconnect there i know that's not
exactly what you're talking about but
i've seen people behave like that oh no
i was i was on a rooftop one time and we
started taking fire and there's some
army dudes i was up there with like a
couple army dudes and we started taking
a little bit of fire and it was you know
choosing whatever and i'm just standing
there and the guys kind of got down and
i was just being you know mr bank mr
badass right hey whatever no factor i'm
colonel kilgore and then all of a sudden
like another like three rounds ripped
really close to her head i
i wasn't so cool anymore so my
self-preservation
was uh
kind of kicked in yeah yeah those ones
are those ones are close yes your
threshold is kind of more further down
and then that's different you gotta
there's a threshold and you see people
have different thresholds and some maybe
the threshold either doesn't exist or
it's so narrow there's no real gap there
that you can observe
um but to say the way he said it i agree
with you like there's i've seen people
do things like that's not what i've seen
no it's not it doesn't happen all the
time but you see it for sure
uh next the negative content of this
counter reflex is the feeling of shame
if
it says you don't stand fast now but run
away the others will laugh at you and
despise you again that's a lot of
thought to be having
in the moment of truth
that's a lot of i mean i've done some
stuff that was dumb or whatever i've
done some stuff where it's like hey
should i be doing this right now maybe
not but i wasn't even thinking about
that i wasn't thinking like oh i don't
want to look bad i was like hey i'm
gonna go whatever across the street
gonna go this whatever
a soldier must therefore be provided
unless nature has done you know what's
another good example is mike thornton i
was you know mike thornton's just
hucking in grenade fights with people
he's shot people are shot there's people
all around him
and i asked him when he was on the
podcast like oh you know were you
thinking you might get shot he's like no
no he said no i don't have time to think
about that what's going on going to save
my friend next question he was almost
embarrassed that i asked that question
he was like dude what is wrong with you
uh a soldier must therefore be provided
unless nature has done the job already
oh so he's got a little caveat so
there's a possibility that nature just
made you brave with a set of automatic
inhibitions that will save him in the
moment of danger from a collapse of his
own morale discipline of course thank
you discipline of course can hold him
steady from without
but his one moral defense against
internal weakness is the sense of honor
to arouse this sense in the ordinary
soldier cultivated and above all inspire
it by his own example is the officer's
highest duty and to fulfill that duty he
must himself have a sense of honor that
is well developed active and finely
tuned
yeah
that's a lot of there's a lot of
preconceived
thought
like the marine corps it back in what
what we coming up on the what
anniversary of the marine corps
1775 minus 20.
yeah 100 a couple hundred and a half
whatever to 250 something years of
and in the marine corps said you know
what we need to do we need to create a
code of honor so that marines
they won't run away like i can't see
that happening no and i'm just thinking
of the basic fundamental training i've
been through as an officer in the marine
corps and i don't remember any of that i
remember being given the code of conduct
and there is unquestionably from day one
you don't want to look bad in front of
your peers right i know that feeling of
getting to like officer candidate school
in the basic school in flight school and
like oh i don't want to look bad i i
understand that feeling but there was a
lot of words there to describe a
situation that almost implies that
you're going to have some sort of
cognitive process to go hmm let me do a
quick cost benefit here of running away
to save my life or you know what my
peers will think of me down the road if
i do that
i can't connect with that right like
three months into the basic school
you're like you know what if anything
happens i'm not gonna run
check
uh to the extent that a code of honor is
reflexive in the sense
used by demeter it is so inflexible
thereby leading on occasions to behavior
that is so irrational as to border on
the absurd that makes sense there are
some times where people have done stuff
that is doesn't make sense
it doesn't make sense what they're doing
like it's heroic
but it doesn't make sense and it's not
even good
uh the following example illustrates the
juxtaposition of bull and honor the year
was 1755. general braddock set out with
his two regiments the 44th and the 48th
and 600 irregulars on a march 2
fort
about nine miles from it he was ambushed
by indians led by french officers the
result was disastrous the men in their
scarlet uniforms
and white spatter dashes marching in
columns where the sort of target ambush
forces dream of aim you can imagine this
here comes the br little british
redcoats here they come marching in
columns and they get ambushed by the
french and the indians helpless because
they could not see their enemies some of
the british troops broke for cover and
fired from behind trees okay cool
this appalled braddock and his officers
they considered skulking behind trees
both undisciplined and unsolderly so
they drove the tommies back into columns
where of course they were butchered
the whole episode was glaring proof that
neither leaders nor the system under
which they operated were worthy of the
troops they used but that's like crazy
right
that's crazy
so unthinkable was it that there's
another example so unthinkable was that
that japanese soldiers would ever
surrender to the enemy that they were
not instructed as to how they should
comport themselves as they did as a
consequence japanese pows were a
relatively fruitful source of
information for allied interrogators i
never thought about that because i've
always heard that when the japanese got
captured they would like spill their
guts but i never thought about why it's
because they never got any training
they're just like oh you will you will
just die no one's gonna surrender oh
actually we're gonna surrender we're
gonna spill our guts
fast forward a little bit talking about
this snob situation snobs
such a good word
a snob is one who is impressed by and
therefore tries to identify with those
who are higher up in the socioeconomic
scale while straining to disassociate
himself from those lower down
by these lights
such everyday affections as name
dropping and paying society magazines to
publish photographs of oneself or one's
nearest family are obvious examples of
snobbishness
name dropping we know echo's big on that
one
i get these uh
what are they called chain emails no not
a chaining like an automatic email yeah
spam emails right
it'll say
congratulations jocko willink you have
been named as ceo of the year or as
entrepreneur of the year or of
entrepreneur of the decade
and we you know congratulations this is
an incredible thing
and
we would want to send you the full
magazine that you will be published in
along with a plaque recognizing your
incredible
achievements as a business leader
and the cost is only one thousand three
hundred and ninety nine dollars
and so it's kind of funny right yeah but
then you gotta remember man i've been to
some people's offices where they got
some plaques on the walls and now i know
where they come from
now i know where they come from
as a general rule snobbish behavior
betokens some underlying feeling of
inferiority
it is a common characteristic of the
social climber of the individual with
low self-esteem of the person who feels
threatened or persecuted because of some
real or imagined
inadequacy so when you deal with someone
that's a snob they actually are feeling
inferior
that there is an underlying pathology to
the condition seems fairly obvious for
two reasons
firstly those who are emotionally secure
are rarely snobbish
isn't that a nice thing to know and
understand if you're emotionally secure
you're not going to be a snob
secondly the behavior is itself
irrational compulsive and self-defeating
after all even the most hardened snob
must know that other people are adept at
seeing through his affections
so you're going to act that way you know
you know people because i explain this
all the time to clients and at the
muster i usually have to spend some time
on this everyone can see what you're
thinking yeah your intent has a smell
it's so obvious
and you know it
and you and deep down you know it
sometimes it's shocking though because i
don't think people do know it i think i
agree with that no i mean to what he's i
think that's what he's saying right
isn't he saying that
unless i'm hearing you incorrectly he's
saying that
deep down you
you know that behavior
is observed by other people
and to me that that's probably like
that's what makes the behavior crazy is
the willingness to to have that thought
and go
no no i can get away with it i can i can
do this differently i can see it in him
super obvious but when i do this it's
not going to come across as snobbish
yeah that's the part for me is like
that's crazy to think that you can pull
it off that is that is crazy and i see
that all the time
people think they're so smart i think no
one's noticing these little maneuvers
they're making it so obvious yeah so
remember i remember when we we went in
on a little
um we were talking about it a lot
for some reason and so i thought about
it and i don't think it's the kind where
they think i'm getting away with it i
don't think that's the thought i think
the thought is like
they're paying attention to what they're
saying and all this stuff but in their
mind instead of oh i look snobby and
dumb or whatever that i'm doing this
name dropping and all that they don't
think that they think oh when i name
drop these people are gonna think that
i'm as cool as i'm trying to be like
it's going to work
but to dave's point they see someone
else's name drop and they go right
freaking echoes over there trying to
name drop
oh yeah it's like but there's all
there's little hints of that like
way of backwards thinking where it
applies to everyone else and not me
right like i'm super paranoid about that
[__] bro and that's a good quality
because then it you know what kind it's
an old joke where
people like give great relationship
advice right they think they give such
good relationship advice but everyone's
like well you don't have any good
relationships you know that kind you
know right so it's kind of everywhere
where
we think that
it applies to everyone else and doesn't
apply to me yeah or it applies to me and
no one else or whatever and that's what
dave's saying same thing it's like oh
this i can i can name drops yes and it's
pretty cool effective exactly right so
cool yeah but they see someone else
thinking yeah
or even the snobby people i know some
stops
unfortunately and i get the same
impression kind of like right because
snobs especially when they're behaving
in a snobby way it looks dumb like it's
kind of embarrassing especially if you
know the person and like them even a
little bit it's kind of embarrassing
like you wish they wouldn't for their
sake act like that but you can tell they
think like oh my gosh these people must
be so impressed with my with my
standards you know my high standards
speaking of just
random emails
i get these i get invites to podcasts
yeah hell yeah and uh the podcast invite
will say
you know recently had this person it's
just
it's literally just a list of
name-dropping stuff yeah and i think to
myself bro what are you doing tell me
about you know what your podcast is
about it's it they don't even play
around they're just like have this
person this person this person this
person this person yeah yeah you think
man
yeah they think there's a little game
too there's a little uh uh status you
know they're one of the they can get you
on then they can get this person on then
they're listing you at every freaking
chance they got that
man oh yeah it's freaking savagery in
the freaking podcast zone
uh
back to the book there is nothing for
example quite so transparent as name
dropping or displaying invitations
he must know at some level this behavior
provokes at best amusement at worst
ridicule contempt or even dislike but he
is nonetheless powerless to curb his
snobbishness
something drives him on i like that i
like i like the way it takes like you
have to drive through it
uh
but why should the military be snobbish
firstly because traditionally top levels
of the military hierarchy were occupied
by the rich and highly born the notions
of socioeconomic military status came
uh it dis
became completely related
then it goes on to say officers are also
stressed from within to know that they
have wedded their lives to essentially
destructive ends that they should
that they should shoulder great
responsibilities that they may be called
upon to carry out tasks far beyond their
capabilities and that the price of
failure is enormous is quite sufficient
to initiate feelings of uneasiness
even notions of retirement are fraught
with stress the knowledge that most
ex-officers have little value on the
civilian labor market that their lot is
of total obscurity of genteel poverty
that they only that only the very best
and very worst of full generals and
above are likely to achieve immortality
and that none of them will ever again
command the absolute obedience to which
they have grown accustomed that can
hardly be described as reassuring
that's kind of crazy right you're in the
military you're an officer
you get out people are look you think
you're still the man
ain't happening
to the factors underlying the
self-protective and compensating aspects
of snobby snobbishness must be added
what is perhaps the most important one
of all
pre-existing doubts of the self
since as we noted earlier there is much
in militarism to attract those with
doubts about their masculinity and
intellectual capacity it would not be
surprising to find that a number of men
with problems over self-esteem will be
discovered at all levels of the military
hierarchy so why do we have a bunch of
snobs well because they're insecure
about who they are
one piece of corroborative evidence for
these views comes from yet another
characteristic of many military
organizations
their notorious sensitivity to criticism
people don't like to be criticized
fast forward about a little bit in
talking of criticism it might seem that
we are making a great deal of fuss about
nothing after all nobody likes criticism
and as far and as for complaints against
military historians it is only natural
indeed laudable that some show loyalty
to one's group because he had gone on to
a little thing about how
some military historians don't say
anything bad about
uh
leaders from the military
but he said you know he said uh that's
understandable because
they kind of have a little bit of hero
worship going on but he goes on to say
there are some special features of the
phenomenon in some military men which
deserve attention in the first place
their sensitivity seems out of all
proportion to that of other public
figures
in terms of fame or notoriety well-known
generals or admirals are on the level
with film stars politicians and even
newsworthy academics
hence one would expect that they might
come to accept the possibility of
negative publicity as part of the game a
small price to pay for the perks which
they otherwise enjoy
this they seem unable to do in fact
there is a distinctly paranoid element
in the way some senior commanders have
reacted to even the faintest breath of
criticism to the vaguest and most
tactful suspicion of a raised eyebrow or
cleared throat almost as if they were
being held personally responsible for
everything that might go wrong
and by the way you should be held for
recovery
there's a lot of irony in that one
so you get these people that are
insecure and they um you know they end
up being
snobs he closes out this section saying
in touching upon this delicate matter we
must not lose sight of this of its
significance and relevance in the
present context whatever else it may be
sensitivity to criticism is a measure of
insecurity
that's so important to remember you look
like so insecure
when you get
offended by criticism
it implies a weak ego which in turn by
way of compensation manifests itself in
particular character traits one of which
is snobbishness
whether this ego weakness is due to some
early shock to self-esteem or fear of
the breakthrough of unacceptable
impulses or some combination of the two
influences the individual so afflicted
develops certain defenses which help to
minimize his painful feelings
this finds support and yet another
feature of military organizations their
cult of anti-effeminacy
going into our next chapter
anti-effeminacy
we don't want to be feminine we want to
be masculine
it says there's a quote in here from
general general chaffee
let war cease altogether and a nation
will become effeminate we just need war
uh he goes here saying when discussing
the various
anxieties which militarism serves to
reduce brief mention was made of the
fears which some men entertain about
their masculinity
this thus it was pointed out
that though primarily concerned with
combating the dread of disorder and
dissolution certain satorial aspects of
[__] might also help to reassure
those with problems in this area
so
what he's saying there is look they they
you you impose discipline because you're
anti-feminist
hey we're not anti
feminine yeah not anti-feminist
anti-feminist feminine
yeah or feministy effeminacy
and and that some of these you know
wearing uh you know imposing your will
on people means you're you're you know
you're not like
feminine right
are we getting into kind of the weird
zone of this book a little bit
[Music]
uh
he says in putting together the jigsaw
of military incompetence therefore we
now we can now take up a piece
one piece which clearly has great
relevance to the topic the striking
aversion towards effeminacy which
characterizes some military
organizations and this despite the fact
that the female is usually regarded as
quote more deadly than the male okay so
i had to
i don't know this was written in 1976
obviously this is a a topic that might
be addressed differently today but what
i did want to do what i did look up is i
said okay what is it what is a feminine
characteristic and what is a masculine
characteristic characteristic generally
speaking yeah
now
okay i'm just going to read them first
masculine this is coming from some
website about psychology right
masculine strong controlled focused
powerful centered purpose driven loves
the challenge and competition single
task oriented problem solver wants
freedom and release
makes big things small
forgets needs admiration and
appreciation wants to be needed and
respected
there the the masculine intimacy killer
is being criticized controlled or shut
out so those the masculine
uh
characteristics here's the feminine
characteristics free flowing open
radiant radiant
wild destructive emotion driven
seeks and gives love nurturer
multitasker diffused awareness
wants to gather talk vent
makes small things big
remembers
needs reassurance and attention wants
trust connection and praise
the intimacy killer is feeling unseen
unsafe or misunderstood now
um
clearly
these things every human has both these
things in a spectrum and
you could call you didn't you
i think what makes them challenging to
talk about in this day and age is they
put man and woman on them what they
should have done is said you know
uh just black and white right two
and yang yeah yeah oh ying and yang
would have been perfect right so you got
the ying personality you got the yang
personality here's how they are not
necessarily men and women because let's
face it we know a lot of women that are
strong controlled and focused we know a
lot of men that are free flowing open
radiate right so these
but i think they're generally speaking
psychologically here's some
characteristics so that's where we're at
dave are you concerned yet
is this the freaking podcast that gets
us banned finally i don't know
no i'm concerned at the depth that this
guy is going into to explain what i
think is going to be a series of
behaviors that we're going to discuss
that are really deep
yes
i it's it's interesting because what
he's saying is and what he says is that
the military can shut out these
feminine characteristics and that's not
good good yeah that's what he's about to
say yeah
that one of the negative characteristics
of a militaristic organization is it
doesn't have enough of the feminine
characteristics for instance
free and open mind right those are bad
if you don't have those those you're in
a bad bad situation
so
he goes on to say uh
evidence of this aversion is of
necessity
circumstantial it embraces such
phenomena so here's some things that
kind of show maybe this this
anti-effeminate
role that you have in the military one
the importance attached to such outward
signs of sex role identification as hair
length
since the insistence on short
back and sides seems correlated with
those periods in history when sexual
differentiation was linked to hair
length we can dismiss excuses of
neatness and hygiene as rationalizations
field marshal lord woolsey stated the
true case when he said
it is very difficult to make an
englishman at any time look like a
soldier he is fond of his longish hair
hair is the glory of a woman but the
shame of a man
so what he's saying is listen it's not
about hygiene it's not about convenience
which by the way i totally disagree with
this i think having short hair is
totally uh convenient
low maintenance
hygienic
neat right that's why i have the hair
that i have
when my hair gets longer than
three quarters of an inch which it
hasn't been for a long time i i can't
stand it
i don't think dang i kind of look wait
i'm looking like a like a woman i need
to shave my head right now not even in
the ballpark so dude i think he's
stretching here
i think he's doing a stretch in fact the
other thing is
how do you make how do you bring
uniformity to a person's hair
you cut it off otherwise you know you
have some dude with long red hair you
got some other dude with curly hair you
got another dude with the with uh
no hair you know you got all these
different hairstyles and all of a sudden
we look different we're not trying to
look different and you know how like
when people girls hang guys by the way
they have like longer hair and it starts
to go in front of their face and they
like whip it back right with their head
that's a that's a functionality thing i
get it but it looks pretty feminine okay
what about when you see a fighter
a professional fighter in the ultimate
fighting championship and he has to
adjust his hair while he's fighting by
the way same gig right same gig it
doesn't make him any less of a fighter
yeah i guess technically right you got
to do one more step for efficiency or
whatever i guess but
you know isn't that a sexual thing when
girls do that like flip their hair
that's like a that's like a mating thing
right
i thought i was just thinking of clay
guinea watching that dude fight and just
like bro how do you see and he's
constantly messing with his hair and it
didn't seem to affect him all that much
that's true and his hair was so freaking
wild it was almost like a target
disrupter yeah like
his hair would be moving around same
thing with big ass beards like how does
that not throw off your punch to
someone's chin when they've got a beard
a big beard that's a problem
i don't know if this is true
but i distinctly remember being told and
i i don't even know who told me but
your hair the one of the reasons they
talked about your hair being short is
they don't want somebody to be able to
use your hair as a as a way to
manipulate your head during hand-to-hand
combat you don't want to grab your head
and you know so i don't remember that
being like in a regulation as the
explanation but being told hey if the
guy can grab your hair and pull your
head because your hair's too long
you're wrong that's to put you at a
disadvantage you can't do that
so 100 yeah my i've always my rule was
this my rule of me but i i will say i
kind of talked to my son about this
however maybe i'm wrong didn't didn't
really tell my daughters this i said hey
if your hair is long enough for someone
to grab then that's a problem you don't
want to have hair that's long enough for
someone to grab i told that to my son
i didn't i might have told to my
daughters but i didn't enforce it
it didn't of course right so i guess i'm
whatever uh what is that sexist yeah
no you're not sexist but you know
yeah what is it when you treat someone
different right you discriminate a
little bit
yeah well whatever although i've told
all i told all my daughters like hey
i can take care of this problem we can
shave that head i always offer my
daughter's haircuts
they've never said yes yeah i say i say
it as a joke
like i don't know if i'd want to shave
my daughter's head but i told my son the
same thing i was like yeah you do want
it short so when you get in a fight or
whatever they can't grab your head or
your hair like that
oh that means that's what it is double
standard double standard the double
standard that's true the doubles
although i didn't i gave them the option
yeah but you didn't enforce it though
wait did you enforce it with your son
though
no but i mean it kind of makes sense hey
man hey so as far as your role and your
level of enforcement it was the same oh
hey how they behave that's different
they got different lies and i get it you
know but hey man no i kind of thought i
might get my middle when my middle
daughter was wrestling yeah you know and
going into some freaking savagery yeah
they don't know wrestling no yeah or
they do no they don't but still let's
face it that's the principle let's face
it you roll it you're you're a female
wrestler and you roll in with the [__]
it's kind of like thug rose right yeah
are we not looking at thug rose thinking
hell yeah
we are we are looking at thinking oh
yeah
even her opponent
yeah she shared her last one yeah
she didn't have her head shaved the
first time but you know my daughter
would get the
cornrow braids like the real tight
braids right that's kind of a war
mode
you can't grab those by the way yeah i
mean in the back yeah well if you have
some kind of a ponytail sticking out the
back but yeah for some reason my
daughter didn't really have that they
were just tight
interesting well done well isn't it the
same for beard though like a big beard
totally like i see a big beard and i'm
like bruh yeah like
it's the exact same thing yeah i look at
someone with a big beard i think
handle you must be super super double
extra confident to think that someone's
not gonna
freaking get a wrist wrap on that bad
boy and slam your head in the pavement
well i feel like the beard is in a less
opportune position i guess technically
still very useful very useful but you
know on the top of the head that's like
i'd say there's like a good level or two
more control yeah it's very shocking
when i see guys with long hair
again you must have a lot of confidence
that someone's not going to grab you and
that's one of my favorite takedowns on
the battlefield just grab a handful of
hair and slam people down it works good
bro watch the
girl fights on youtube
if you have the time bro that's that's
gonna be the default at some point
they're just gonna grab hair and it's
like they kind of nullify both attacks
when they're both grabbing hair so it's
man it's like proof you know in the
field yeah field proven combat scenario
drunk chicks scrapping it out on youtube
it's totally true it's totally true
okay
this is a rough topic
traditional taboos on certain topics and
pastimes
thus we find captain
foley
commander of britannia naval training
establishment for officer cadets at
dartmouth forbidding piano playing
because he considered it effeminate
so these are the kind of dudes that are
weird right this dude's got issues
you know and he's going hard against
piano playing because he's got some
weird stuff going on yeah right yeah
another one a deeply rooted prejudice
toward women who try to adopt
traditional male roles
see that
finally an equation between defensive
behavior
and effeminacy so if you're on defense
that means you're being effeminate
the feeling that it is [__]
to wear to wear ear protectors or build
head covers has undoubtedly caused much
unnecessary unnecessary destruction of
the human body
it is not an unreasonable hypothesis to
suggest that its most glaring and costly
illustration occurred in connection with
the issue of convoys
in the first world war hundreds of
thousands of tons of merchant shipping
was lost through the navy's refusal to
adopt the convoy system
when lloyd george eventually forced
convoys upon an unwilling admiralty
losses fell significantly so
their idea was hey i'm in charge of my
ship i'm not gonna i'm not gonna go with
a pack i'm not weak i'm not going in a
convoy
that's weak i'm a man and i'm gonna take
this thing solo and they were losing
chips all the time finally someone say
hey bro you guys got to stick together
yeah
uh the lesson was plain for all to see
but in the years between the wars the
same irrational dislike of mothering a
flock of ships prevented the development
of an efficient escort system
so the brits
the brits started taking losses in world
war one and world war ii same freaking
bad move
then the amer then america entered the
war and unbelievably in the face of
overwhelming evidence insisted on trying
to defeat u-boats without the use of
convoys same thing
this is world war ii we already know
that you should stick together
between december 1941 and the following
march american losses of merchant
shipping grew to the staggering monthly
total of 500 000 tons eventually the
price of aggressive masculinity embodied
in the so-called patrol and hunting
operations of isolated warships proved
too costly and convoys were instituted
between boston and halifax losses on
this route promptly dropped to zero
but south of boston's
boston ship still sailed independently
until june the number of ships sunk
reached an all-time record of 700 000
tons in a single month they still didn't
do it
yeah it's considered weak it's
considered feminine yeah that's the
okay hindsight 20 20. i get it but when
you kind of think of the big picture it
makes more sense than it might appear
at first because remember back in the
day when seat belts
weren't uh what do you call legal like
or it was legal still to not wear your
seat belt right then there's like
and then there was a little transition
period where it's like yeah if you don't
wear your seatbelt it's kind of like ah
like you're being what are you scared
like kind of weak or whatever same thing
with the kids and the helmets like oh
yeah you're just riding in the
cul-de-sac right now brad the helmet is
that even necessary or you see the kids
with the elbow pads you know it's kind
of like
okay cool you're safe but come on let's
say that's kind of weak you know
um
and but let's
the truth is bro if if you care about
like the safety or whether it be
efficiency safety uh not dying like all
these things bro the going to make a lot
of sense right after a while
you're going to kind of realize that
then it's like okay what's more cool now
living
or not wearing that helmet yep
yeah that's uh that's a good one that's
so i see i see what you're saying state
of mind is what i'm saying so it took
these guys a little while to get over
the state of mind like hey we kind of
look like a [__] yeah yeah exactly
because
of
we're going in a convoy yeah i don't
need nobody holding my hand yeah you
know i got this
yeah
did any of your dudes not want to wear
ipro remember i pro those clear
in what situation
going out in in on literally going out
on a mission yeah
[Music]
and i'll tell you why it had nothing to
do with
if depending on how much movement was
taking place sweaty that [__] just
kept sweating [__] i sweat a lot and
they would be not they wouldn't be
functional for me that's that is a
legitimate that's a legitimate reason to
do it too plus do i look like a [__]
yeah
no well that that if you could wear ipro
you should if you can you should yeah
and i only asked that because i remember
that being
a like long conversation with with folks
not just on my team but all the people
who were with about not wearing ipro out
on missions not the fogging and the
sweating that was saying which i fully
understandable and there was different
ways different ones to do it and dudes
didn't want to do it because they didn't
like the way it looked
really well all you had to do was
authorize them to wear freaking
sunglasses yeah you can't get them
it's weird though because i always wear
sunglasses always always wear sunglasses
but i never wore sunglasses in the field
yeah ever
and i don't know
they seemed like just in the way plus
they would fog up they would get sweaty
yeah is there anything in um i guess in
the battlefield it might be more black
and white but like in training or
something like that where it's like
maybe something optional or something
that people don't want to wear or do
that's for safety reasons but it's like
it's like it's not cool or it's like
okay or whatever
there's a ton of things in aviation
gloves are always a big one
yeah dudes didn't want to wear gloves
and then they'd always show like these
videos of like post ejection trauma to
your hands
or fingers getting literally they'd call
it getting de-gloved
when you're um skin would come off your
hand and leave the um
the bone behind that pictures of guys
exiting the cockpit on injections and
stuff or getting burned and things like
that but flight gloves would stop you
from getting de-gloved yes so
um
if you have like a
a ring or or you're climbing up or
something like that and and um you
didn't have something covering that that
could get caught there's a famous
picture all the any aviator listening to
this will know exactly what i'm talking
about there's a famous picture like the
gazette or whatever a magazine of a
dude's hand on the table like this who's
wearing his wedding ring and his hands
there this whole thing is gone all this
errors is the the remaining piece of
bone left on his hand
you know trying to get people to wear
gloves people didn't want to wear gloves
did you wear a wedding ring
yes under your gloves
yes
did you always wear gloves
yes i was a glove wearer
and then why would you not want to wear
gloves the complaint was like oh it's
the tactile like i want to press the
buttons and turn the knobs and it's
harder to feel and like can you cut the
fingertips out yes did you do that no
just full on i just wore gloves now what
would eventually happen is like you'd
wear through them and sometimes the
fingers would actually you probably even
see them in the videos i'm like moving
my things up and down and the gloves are
kind of afraid and whatnot
but um it was just to your point it was
a conversation that i was found odd
to be quite honest the reason i wore
gloves is like the first day of flight
school the guy was like you will wear
your gloves i'm like okay i know i'm not
here to like use to it i'm not here to
like tell you i don't like the way it
feels i didn't even think about it i put
my gloves on and strapped them on and
that was the end of that
i never found my own style like halfway
like you know i don't like this
yeah yeah it wasn't in my i didn't i
wasn't didn't care think about those
things and you got used to it totally
and once you get used to it it doesn't
really matter there's no factor right
yeah it's no factor at all but there are
people that
these are conversations and i think to
the point is like
those conversations about i'm not
wearing this for the functionality
versus i don't like the way it looks
those are two totally different things
you tell me it gets fogged up i can't
see sweat i remember sweat beads running
down the glass and like these things are
gone immediately
versus as i look in the mirror am i i'm
all kidded up i'm about to go i don't
like the way i look i'm not i'm not
having those conversations in my mind
about how i look when i'm doing this
yeah well
the fact of knowing you can get your
freaking shrapnel in your eyes you know
little chunks of brass in your eyes
little chunks of crap in your eyes like
that sucks especially dave burke who has
a 100 plan of going back to flying an
airplane with his whole ground situation
is over you were like i'm preserving my
eyes dude
eyes are number one protected
uh um
so he goes on to this section here
where he starts using this term butch
and it's not it
it's just basically saying like i guess
we'd say like
hyper manly like a manly man he uses
this term butch he says by selecting and
promoting on the basis of such butch
criteria
as size strength physical courage and
prowess at games the armed forces tend
to ignore other attributes
which
really may be of even greater importance
to a senior commander intelligence high
educational level resistance of
breakdown under stress and substantial
reserves of moral courage
well clearly
this goes down where we're just picking
the kind of the toughest dude to be in
charge instead of the smartest dude
not that the smartest dude is
necessarily the right one either
because we see smart people that are
really dumb
there is of course a counter argument
namely that generals should be heroic
leaders which would necessitate them
having at least some of the
aforementioned butch traits sheer
physical size the possession of
decorations for bravery and a fine
rugger record
would according to this argument confer
invaluable leadership qualities upon top
military commanders
unhappily this millet this theory does
not stand up and by rugger he means a
rugby player
being good at rugger in no way ensures
the best qualities of military
leadership
so-called masculine attributes count for
very little in comparison with
personality and knowing one's job
the most cursory glance
at military history suggests that many
of the really great military and naval
commanders napoleon nelson wolff for
instance were men of brain and character
not of huge bodies with dazzling records
in the field of sport
of general ship montgomery says the
science and art of command
involves an intimate knowledge of human
nature
a commander must think two stages ahead
he speaks glowingly of the physical
physically frail wolf and nelson
describing the latter as a brilliant
semen and most original intelligent and
courageous fighter
in the same vein he comments on the
flexibility and brilliant intellect of
napoleon but nowhere does the field
marshal
talk about the advantages of fine
physique hairy masculinity and a
reputation for long distance running
polo or boxing
so these manly traits
butch traits according to this book
might not be the most important thing in
fact he's indicating that they are not
the most important thing
we are concerned to relate and explain
two indisputable phenomenon so-called
peaceful generals who in times of stress
reveal themselves as passive dependent
and indecisive
and the anti-effeminacy ethos of some
military organizations to handle these
facts the following points were made
some men for reasons rooted in early
family situation have serious doubts
about their sexual adequacy and or
physical strength and size such men may
deal with their feelings of inferiority
by adopting a compensatory
style of life
in which they strive for reassurance in
some suitably symbolic role
the prevailing ethos of many military
organizations provides this reassurance
hence a percentage of men will seek
acceptance by the armed forces simply
because such acceptance is a warranty of
their masculinity
once in their continuing and underlying
feat of a fear of effeminacy produces
that well-known pattern of behavior
which we have termed butch
but this
behavior is is itself highly valued in
the armed forces hence the individual
not only profits by but also contributes
to the anti-effeminacy of his parent
organization it is in his interest to do
so
and last the significance of all this
for military incompetence is that butch
characteristics are not perhaps the most
important criteria for top level
leadership
so he's talking about and when i was
thinking about this
uh you definitely see some people like
this where you can see that they're in
the military
to try and maybe compensate for some
fears in their own head
and i think it's real obvious just like
we talk the obviousness of someone
that's a snob someone that's a name
dropper
cause
let's face it there's some guys in the
military that are 100 bad ass military
dudes and like that's just how they are
uh this idea that you get some people
that are countering their innate
feminine traits by just trying to act
super tough
you see some of those guys i don't think
it's very widespread you certainly see
some of them
but it's not
it's not that common when you see it
it's very obvious that that's what
you're dealing with they're usually over
the top with their behavior
uh but then i think the most important
thing that he's saying is that
in the military sometimes that
you start to focus on that and we don't
want someone that's gonna raise their
hand and and have an open mind to stuff
or gonna gonna i mean think about some
of these feminine feminist traits that
are good
multitasker right
wants to talk communicate
remembers things
um
free
flowing and open
right
emotion driven we talk all the time
about the fact that we don't want people
to make emotional decisions but you
don't want someone that doesn't have any
emotion because that's how you end up
with a commander that's just sending
people to their death
so to
well that's why we wrote the dichotomy
of leadership all these
masculine and feminine traits
you need them both and you need to have
balance you need to have balance in the
individuals and then you need to have
balance in a unit you might have so
you're going to need some people in your
platoon that just are killers
but if you have a whole platoon filled
with killers that's going to be a
problem and you need to have some people
in your uh platoon that are very
empathetic
but if you have a whole platoon of
apathetic people you're not going to be
able to get any missions done so you
need a balance of these feminine
feminine and masculine traits you need
to have the proper balance of yin and
yang yes sir
so where does
toxic masculinity fit into all this or
is this just talking about toxin but but
since it was written back in you know
yeah before the term before the term the
toxic masculinity i wrote an article
about this one time toxic masculinity is
when you take any of the mass considered
traditional masculine traits and you
take them to an extreme
and then you end up with someone that's
quote toxic masculine
so
here's the thing when i wrote that
article i wrote about because they were
saying you know being competitive is a
toxic masculine trait no it's not it's a
good trait to have
uh being strong
that's a masculine trait is it toxic
no
do uh what's another one
um
being purpose driven
that's a masculine trait according to
this list
is that a bad thing if you take it to an
extreme where you've got someone that's
they just want to win and then smash
people yeah that's bad if you want
someone that wants to be just so strong
and powerful that they'll just step on
other people that's bad so if you take
any of these things to an extreme
they're a problem
and what i ended up saying in that
article there's these these are good
characteristics for for a person to have
including
my three daughters i want my daughters
to be assertive i want them to be strong
i want them to be
competitive
what you want you don't want your
daughters to be like that no of course
you want your sons to be like that too
do you want your any of your kids to go
too far in those directions no
absolutely not
so
the toxic masculinity i think is when
you start taking any of these
characteristics to the extreme it
becomes a problem
does that answer your question yeah i'm
wondering just if this is essentially
like what he's talking about before it
was actually like a phrase yeah and i
think if you get an organization where
they've gone too far in one direction
it's a problem yeah
now listen we got just people that are
just following orders just ultra
obedient
because that's what the the masculine
thing is we just wanna we we wanna obey
and be part of the team okay cool yeah
not good
chapter 20 leaders of men how can the
ability to lead depend on the ability to
follow you might as well say that the
ability to float depends on the ability
to sync
that's an interesting quote which i
don't agree with
the ability to lead
you don't necessarily no sorry
in order to
follow
you don't necessarily doesn't know
doesn't mean necessarily you're going to
be a good leader but if you're going to
be a good leader you better know how to
follow as well
so that quote right there which is from
the peter principle don't agree with it
whatever its other causes military
incompetence implies a failure in
leadership this is hardly surprising of
psychological problems which beset
military officers few exceed and
severity those associated with
leadership in this respect they are
required to fulfill incompatible roles
they are expected to show initiative
yet remain hemmed in by regulations they
must be aggressive yet never
insubordinate they must be assiduous in
caring for their men
yet maintaining enormous social distance
they must know everything about
everything yet never appear intellectual
finally as we saw in the last chapter
they may well have been selected for
attributes almost totally unrelated to
the task they are expected to perform so
that's an entire list of dichotomies of
leadership
right
sir
discussions of leadership is so often
overloaded with vague but emotive ideas
that one is hard to put the nail
to nail the concept down so now he's
trying to come up with a with a
definition for leadership
to cut through the panoply of such
quasi-moral and unexceptionable
associations as patriotism
play up and play the game never asking
your men to do something you wouldn't do
for yourself
not giving up the square jaw frank eyes
of steadfast gays these are all like
these sort of leadership things if
you'll if you'll be a man recipe so he's
given all these kind of traditional
quotes about leadership and then he
gives his
the simple truth that leadership is no
more than exercising such an influence
upon others that they tend to act in
concert towards achieving a goal which
they might not have achieved so readily
had they been left to their own devices
fair enough
is that an epic definition of leadership
not really
[Music]
but
it's a decent one the ingredients which
bring about this favorable state of
affairs are many and varied
the most superficial level
at the most superficial level they are
believed to include such factors as
voice
stature and appearance impression of
omniscience
trustworthiness sincerity and bravery
at a deeper and rather more important
level leadership depends on a proper
understanding of the needs and opinions
of those one hopes to lead
and the context in which leadership
occurs
so that's a great definition well not so
much a definition but it's a great point
hey your voice your stature
your trustworthiness your sincerity your
bravery those things are all important
but guess what's even more important
understanding the needs and opinions of
the people you're leading
that's what he's saying right there
so he nails that part
straight up
in short there's nothing mysterious
romantic or necessarily laudable about
leadership in military organizations
leaders are appointed
rather than emergent
that is to say the needs of the
individual soldier play almost no role
in deciding
the sort of leader he gets secondly the
military leader possesses constitutional
power of a magnitude which surpasses
that of leaders in most other human
groups if he cannot pull his followers
by force of character he can at least
push them by force of law yeah i don't
really buy into that too much
that's like
you know
because in the civilian world oh you
don't want to do what i'm telling you
call i'm going to fire you
which you can do just like in the
military you can say shut up and do what
i told you to do because i
you know i i have the backing of the
constitution behind me
neither one of those are good leadership
and they won't pan out for very long
the third and related feature of
military leadership is that it
essentially is essentially autocratic
and operates in what modern theorists
call a wheel net
rather than an all-channel communication
net
in other words the flow of essential
information is to and fro between the
leader and his subordinates rather than
between all members of the group
not very surprisingly the wheelnet
though no doubt gratifying to autocratic
leaders produces more errors slower
solutions to problems and reduce
gratification to the group than does the
more democratic all channel net that's
interesting
you want to participate with your whole
group
i think that's how i operate it doesn't
really matter who comes with an idea
we're good with it let's share it
in light of these considerations it is
perhaps strange that leadership in the
british armed forces should have been as
effective as it has
so he's like saying it's amazing that
the british military was so effective
because they freaking operate on these
principles that suck
since a salient feature of all and by
the way you want to know why the
soldiers the soldiers get the job done
since a salient feature of all the
campaigns so far considered has been a
remarkable absence of the mutinous
tendencies and a quite astonishing
degree of tolerance fortitude and
bravery shown by the common soldier we
have to ask was this despite or because
of their leaders so i'm gonna go ahead
and say despite in many cases
yeah it
i saw this with many many platoons over
the years
you could have bad leadership
but if you have a few pipe hitters in
there
they will make things happen and that
platoon will be successful
even with bad leadership
despite the leadership they'll be
successful the first point of note is
the distinction that has to be drawn
between two roles of a leader task
specialist and social specialist
a task specialist's
a leader's prime concern
as sorry as a task specialist a leader's
prime concern is to achieve the group's
goal in the case of the military
defeating the enemy
for such a role being likable is rather
less important trait than that of being
more active more intelligent and better
informed than his followers
in his capacity as a social specialist
however a leader's main function is to
preserve good personal relations with
the group
and within the group thereby maintaining
morale as to keep the group in being
in the military meloo
the function of a successful social
specialist would prevent mutiny and
reduce such symptoms as low morale
absenteeism
desertion sickness and crime not very
surprisingly the most important
attribute of such a leader is that he
should be liked
efficiency and task ability are of
rather secondary opportu importance so
this is something i think i wrote
leadership strategy and tactics
what is a leader trying to do build
relationships in that team not just
between yourself but between the whole
team that's what we're trying to do
that's what we're here for
and that task thing kind of works itself
out
if you're doing a good job building
those relationships that task thing is
going to kind of handle itself
i'm just having such a hard time he's
using so many words and and what i'm
actually trying to do is is
get my head wrapped around like 1970s
england that's what i'm trying to do
because it's like hey how about i take
those 12 pages and just write balance
you know what i mean uh
and and yeah even inside that just like
you and i think the order in which you
said it is the right thing is if
he called it like democratic we all feel
part of it as everybody thinks i care
about you
if my people think i care about them
they're going to get on board with the
plan
and if i'm an autocrat and i tell people
what to do and they have to do what they
say no matter what they're going to
struggle with the plan
and if you go with that second that
first one
they'll do even harder things
that are more challenging more
life-threatening and less likely to be
successful on paper or at least it to
their own risk
than if they don't think that i care
about them they'll be less likely to do
hard things like
combat
and then inside that the little subtle
point and i'm glad you said exactly the
exact same thought is even when that
leadership doesn't reveal itself which
it clearly has not
there's another layer of leadership
inside there you know you could call
your ncos whatever the term that you
want to use those those pipe hitters
inside the organization
they're still going to make it happen
yeah
yeah and just to make sure everyone
understands when you want your team to
think you care about them how do you
make that happen
you have to care about
and i shouldn't say
i should use a different word
when they believe that
not when they think that like i'm trying
to convince them of that when they come
to believe that and go oh
yep
this guy cares he really does that's
that is a that's a better way to
describe and that's really what you're
saying not that i i i manipulate them to
thinking that it's when they recognize
it for themselves and they and they see
that and they believe that
it says here it has been shown
that whereas low-stressed groups
operating in situations that are devoid
of painful uncertainties do best under
democratic leadership organizations like
the military in times of war that are
subject to stressing ambiguities
actually prefer
autocratic leadership
in other words the feelings of
dependency induced by stress successful
successfully neutralize a person's
normal
um adversity toward the autocratic
leader
while a man like townsend would not be
likely to survive for very long in a
modern civilian firm his autocratic
mean was lovingly accepted by men whose
lives were hanging by a thread
so the reason that he points all this
out is that these guys some of these
guys like townsend
they still listen to him
they obey him
and what's interesting about this is
he's making a huge generalization
of organizations like the military and
times of war are subject to stressing
ambiguity's prefer autocratic leadership
let me tell you where the subtlety here
is
98 99
of the time even in a war
we want democratic leadership and there
is a moment in time where there's
confusion where there's chaos where
there's mayhem where everyone is looking
at the leader to make a call that
happens in the military it happens in
business too i mean uh when echelon
front hit covid
right
uh hey we heard a bunch of ideas and
then i became a little bit autocratic
like hey here's what we're doing
boom
and everyone was stoked going hell yeah
that's what they were and the thread
that's inside both of those
and i think why autocratic behavior when
you're the recipient of that why you're
willing to be treated like that or
directed
if i have already made the connection in
my mind that the thing that you're
making me do that you're directing me to
do
is designed to help me keep me alive
when my when that that thread hangs in
or the life hangs in the balance
whatever the word he just used there if
i make that connection and go
he's telling me to do this and would i
know what he i know why he's telling me
this dude i'll follow orders all day
long it doesn't even bother me it
doesn't bother me told what to do to be
mandated anything from my boss if i go
oh
i see what's happening here yep i'm
gonna go execute
now if you spend your whole career being
an autocrat and just telling me what to
do
dude i got news for you even when you
actually need in those rare two three
percent occasions you need to do that
you're gonna have a very very hard time
getting your people to follow you yeah
this is a point that i made
deeply in leadership strategy and
tactics when i talk about leadership in
a va in the leadership vacuum and i mean
i went into some specifics in there like
letting that vacuum exist for just a
second longer just to make sure everyone
feels it i would make sure i'd wait an
extra half a second or one second before
i said anything to make sure everyone
knew oh damn we don't know what we're
doing right now and they are waiting to
be led they are waiting for that that
autocratic leader to step and say
everyone lock it up we're moving to that
building and they are so on board for
that if you make that call a little too
early you get resistance some people hey
how do you know what no you gotta let it
you gotta let it just
let it be there for a moment let
everyone see oh it's a vacuum i don't
know what to do
and then boom and if you wait too long
well then
other people are chirping in with their
ideas you can get some confusion so you
gotta time that very well but but it's
unfortunate that he says he kind of
blankets the whole thing because it's
not true it's not a blanket statement
even in war people want to have more say
as what's happening he's also doing one
thing that that i don't agree with
either is he's drawing some contrast
between this military leader and that
military leaders inability to be
successful in the private sector because
the military responds to these type of
behaviors and the private sector doesn't
[Applause]
well when he's talking about that he's
talking about the fact that if you have
an uh
authoritarian leader in the civilian
it's gonna be less successful here's a
point that i made the other day which
you actually no i agree with you you're
right that doesn't make sense here
here's why
and he doesn't point this out in this
book i pointed this out the other day
in the
military bad leaders can get promoted
easier than bad leaders can get promoted
in the civilian sector why is that
because in the military
you're gonna be in charge how long were
you in charge of your
squadron for two years and that's what
that's what a military leader gets yep
so
you get two years
and by the time the enlisted guys figure
out this guy's a jackass it takes him
six months to confirm that and then it's
like okay well now we're starting our
work up we actually don't think hey
he'll be gone forget about it and that
guy dave burkett's promoted cause he did
his job he did it correctly no one said
anything boom whereas civilian world
like you're in charge of that whatever
division for years
and everybody knows it that's another
thing military oh you oh you did one
you know one command deployment here in
virginia then you're going to san diego
then you're going to bahrain then you're
just traveling around and you can get
away with it
so
that's one of the reasons i think why
the uh why the military can produce some
bad leaders yes and they can get
promoted yeah as long as that comment
you made is understood that this success
in the private sector comparison of the
success in the military sector your
point is the bad leaders might stick
around
they're not good leaders by virtue of
the military environment they're bad
leaders that are being that are sticking
around because the military has a
mechanism that sort of allows for it but
just i just i don't like the thought
that there's a distinction that military
leader
good military leadership is different
from other types of leadership that's
100 accurate yeah
fast forward a little bit
but even given the right circumstances
an autocratic mean is no bar to being
liked
we still need
some more positive reasons for this
extraordinary popularity of otherwise
incompetent commanders
so he talks about the fact that like why
do you still like why did these guys
like townsend who got a bunch of his men
killed why did they still like him why'd
they still follow him um
one of the reasons he talks about is
successful leadership attempted to occur
if followers had been indulged by their
leaders
that makes sense right oh if you had
actually taken care of your guys they
would be more likely to follow you well
that makes sense
that actually makes sense that's a good
reason
a situation in which the motivational as
opposed to the intellectual aspects of
leadership may lead to military
disasters where obedience evoked by hero
worship blunts reason and moral
sensitivity to such an extent that the
group may embark on a behavior which is
little short of suicidal again he's
trying to figure out why
in some situations do people that are
idiots still get followed
uh there is however one further aspect
of these more nebulous qualities of
leadership which has
played a not inconsiderable part in the
story of military incompetence it it
concerns the position
which an individual occupies on two
related continua
those of boldness to caution and
impulsiveness to indecision over the
years of military incompetence has
resulted
more from a dearth of boldness than from
a lack of caution and more from a pall
of indecision than an excess of
impulsivity so he's saying that most of
the problems that occur
don't they don't occur because
action is taken to impulsive action they
actually caught happen for the other
reason don't want to do anything that's
why the term default aggressive exists
because if you don't do anything
chances are it's going to be bad your
default mode should be to make something
happen
real quick not to interrupt it so
autocratic what exactly is that
it's close to authoritarian but it's
weird he he uses the term autocratic
it's like hey i'm in charge i'm in
control it's one person in control
charging in control but he
differentiates
between autocratic meaning like listen
hey i'm the guy in charge i'm gonna tell
us where to go and authoritarian which
is very strong-handed form of autocratic
rule okay
he doesn't necessarily
he gives an autocratic a little bit of
negativity but he's also like hey you're
in a platoon that's the platoon
commander it's it's autocratic what he
says we're gonna do
that is the reality of the situation
the the better reality is a democratic
97 percent of the time three percent of
time autocratic three percent of the
time hey i'm in charge this is what
we're gonna make happen right now we
gotta make this happen now boom yeah
it's in it like
because you kind of kind of think i
remember okay you know how you have
entrepreneurs and then you have like
employee types right yes and then you
like certain personalities go along with
each one
way better right for sure because some
people let's face it like they just tell
me where to be what time yeah and tell
me what to do man oh and they'll go hard
and they'll go and they'll do it they'll
get it
get the job done super good you know
within their little
within their job description scope you
know and then some people they go crazy
with that kind of stuff
and then they just rather like think and
go out color outside the lines and all
this stuff you know so it's like so the
autocratic is kind of maybe for people
who are yeah like that right but here's
the thing
there's
everyone has a spectrum right and
there's going to be times
where if you're working for me echo
there's going to be times like dude why
is this guy bossing me around and
there'd be other times you'd be waiting
for me to tell you what to do even you
yeah as a one human can have you can you
can
transit across that spectrum
and what i'm saying is when there's a
lot of pressure on and there's mayhem
going on
most people are going to want
somebody to tell them what to do yeah i
shouldn't say most many many people are
going to say dude you need to tell me
what to do right now
because there's bad stuff going on i'm
running that scene and saving private
ryan right at the beginning right that
crazy part yep and then he kind of loses
his hearing or something like that then
someone's like he just kind of
like
snaps too and this guy's in front of him
saying what do we do now sir that's a
classic yeah it's kind of like that
that's a classic example of
hey those guys are looking to be led
yeah at that moment and it took a lot to
get them to that point but there they
are yes sir so that's a good one
one of the obvious explanations for the
failure of motivational aspects of
leadership is in all these instances
related to the advanced age of the
individuals concerned old men are more
cautious than young men and less able to
make quick decisions than those whose
arteries have not begun to harden
i've cut out a lot of the jokes this guy
is a funny guy i will say
there
are other more fundamental and pervasive
reasons for these failures in leadership
which can be ascribed to the general
psychopathology of military
organizations their common denominator
is anxiety it is a feature of armed
services that the penalty for error is
very much more substantial than the
reward for success
that is
so important to remember for your
organization
the penalty for error is way harder than
the reward you get when you do something
good that's absolutely true in the
military so what kind of people do you
end up with
right
whereas the naval officer who through an
error of judgment on the part of his
subordinates puts his ship aground will
almost certainly be court-martialed and
stands a fair chance of being heavily
punished the reward for taking a bold
action which pays off may be no more
than a mention in a dispatch or some
decoration with little or no effect upon
promotional aspects
the net result of this bias towards
negative reinforcement will be that fear
of failure rather than hope of success
tends to be the dominant motive force in
decision making and the higher rank the
stronger this motive
there is farther to fall this is a good
thing to remember with your kids
right with your kids you don't want your
kids operating out of fear of making a
mistake you want your kids operating on
the hope of being successful
finally mentioned must be made of a
thesis put forward by simon raven which
may bode ill for the future concerns the
role of false premises in the training
of officers false premises that have
their origin in a simple and obvious
fact that an expectation of superiority
in a leader by those who led will
increase the tendency to follow him this
is this was kind of strange
for years it was the case that since
they were drawn from a socioeconomic
class that was vastly inferior to that
of the officers the rank and file took
for granted that their officers knew
more than they did and were in a very
real sense born to lead i.e were born
into that class which traditionally the
core of officers was drawn that's the
way it used to be you kind of were a
whatever a peasant and you had this lord
that was your officer and you're like
hey dude this dude's supposed to be in
charge so i'm kind of going to listen to
him
since the last word that has changed
this has changed officers are no longer
recruited exclusively from the upper
classes comparatively few are landed
from gentry or aristocratic families and
many have not even attended a public
school which a public school in england
is a private school
by the same token
the rank and file are better educated
and more sophisticated than their
forbearers so the troops are more
educated
at first bless this would seem
all to the good giving promise of a
democratization uh in the profession of
arms a trend which would one day place
on it on par with most other vocations
in civilized society unfortunately
according to raven
smith simon raven's thesis something
quite other is happening confronted with
the necessity of recruiting its officers
from a section of society that would
have been unthinkable in years gone by
the military has made it
made what it regards as the best of a
bad job by insisting that since officers
must still be gentlemen
where no natural gulf exists between
those who lead and those who follow this
must be artificially inculcated by
training so
this is a little bit hard to follow but
i'm gonna just give a little detail here
so you used to have these people that
were lords or whatever
and so the troops were freaking peasants
and they're like cool this guy's a lord
i should probably be listening to him
he's a gentleman he he purports himself
as a leader cool
i'm gonna tend to follow him
then all of a sudden they started
recruiting officers from
wherever and now they had to say wait a
second they still need to be
gentlemen so we're going to inculcate
this difference into them we're going to
make them into
a higher class
what does inculcate like uh
sort of put that seed into them we're
gonna we're gonna turn them into that
we're gonna plant this in them as far as
just an idea or like really like or like
okay we're gonna inculcate these people
we're gonna train them to be that or are
we just gonna apply that seed in
everyone's head so it seems like well
yeah so what he says is artificially
inculcated so he's like we're gonna fake
this we're gonna try and make these
people seem as if
they're of a higher class which is like
that right there we should already be
thinking uh oh
right
the following excerpts from raven's
article should make the matter plain we
start with a glimpse of life at the
royal military academy and later at the
school of infantry at warminster
in the 1950s according to raven the
products of this training regimen may be
as bizarre as those depicted in the four
character studies which conclude this
section
here we go saluting at sandhurst is
tremendous if you walk round sandhurst
looking remotely as if you might be an
officer you will receive an incessant
barrage of compliments
the muddy boy and pee t-shirts will stop
running squares shoulders and snap his
eyes in your direction like knives
the elegant young gentleman in the brown
trilby will lift it from his head with a
controlled jerk to replace it an exact
number of seconds later at precisely the
same angle boys in uniform with sticks
swords rifles or submachine guns will
perform a volume of intricate movements
alone or as a body especially for your
benefit
so they're trying to make people think
they're you know elevated
to the detached observer these quaint
antics
may seem ludicrous boring or even
faintly embarrassing however
there will be others so emotionally
incapable of distinguishing between
compliments paid to the abstractions of
rank and commission and those paid to
themselves as people that they will
actually enjoy these gesticulations ooh
this is where the trouble starts homie
this is when you are going to you know
you're going to ocs or wherever you're
getting trained and you start thinking
you're damn right you're saluting me
you you are saluting me
but such enjoyment of these mandatory
conventions based upon a highly
motivated if understandable
misinterpretation of their meaning may
like the effects of even the most
transparent flattery provoke wholly
unrealistic feelings of self-importance
oh
you know what's kind of weird it is kind
of weird
in the military
one of the big distinctions is you get
caught his officers get called sir
right yes so think about that you you're
an officer you get called sir it doesn't
matter if you're 21 years old and you
just graduated from ocs or you just
graduated from the academy you're
getting called sir
so there's some people that go man you
know what it's really awkward to be
called sir when i'm actually 22 years
old and this guy's 38 years old that's
kind of weird but i get it's the
military convention
that's a great attitude to have yeah and
you know what there is a level of
respect even when a seasoned
non-commissioned officer a platoon chief
calls up calls a young officer sir and
he does it in a respectful way and
there's a known
it it doesn't need to be said it's like
hey i'm giving you your props right it's
good yeah that's the way the rank
structure works and it is like this just
beautiful relationship
yeah but then there's some people that
go yeah you're damn right you call me
sir yeah
yeah it's like the
like okay like the seasoned guy calling
the new guy sir whatever if he's a
officer that's almost like it's respect
for the whole institution
yes 100
yeah it's respect for the whole thing
and and a good young officer goes man
man that's
a little bit uncomfortable that's the
kind of the deal here i get it and the
and so there's also
there's also enlisted guys that go
through that phase of like who the hell
i'm not calling this guy sir that's
freaking ridiculous
they'll call i'll call you lieutenant
i'm not calling you sir sir is for my
grandfather so again they go through
that phase
young enlisted guys will go through that
phase
of like hey i'm not calling this guy sir
um
other significant features of the
sandhurst meloo according to raven are
the perfect system wherein cadets of
higher rank are required to discipline a
report upon those of lower status the
mind blunting drill square upon which
three apparent essentials
for a career of violence unthinking
obedience and exquisite capacity for
keeping in step and a proper concern for
the minutia of dress are instilled for
hour upon hour until fatigue and sweat
hang over the masked cadets like
brimstone over sodom
and finally the total loss of privacy
and lack of leisure for the following of
idiosyncratic interest and pastimes
taken together the features of the royal
military academy are designed to quote
build character and imbue
future officers with values proper to
their calling any gaps which sandhurst
might leave in a total program for the
inculcation of an officer-like quality
are admirably filled up says raven by
the quasi-morale imperatives of war
minister
these cluster around the concepts of
guts enthusiasm humor sociability and
responsibility traits which every
officer should show so they got done
with sandhurst which is like their
military college now they're they're
they're advanced school
this place warminster and whatever they
didn't get it
whatever didn't whatever gaps there are
they're going to go even harder
at warminster while much of the training
was inevitably designed to promote
physical fitness there was never less a
strong held belief that an officer
whether fit or not should always have so
much in the way of pride or guts that he
would never admit to physical inadequacy
until he dropped dead or unconscious
this belief a very significant one was
both mythical was mystical both in
nature and intensity now we're kind of
talking about that that's kind of a
badass thing though right it's kind of a
badass thing hey you are not going to
give up
you're not going to stand down doesn't
matter you're ready or not you put on
that rucksack you're going to finish
this day of march that's what's
happening
this was interesting another
warminster virtue was a peculiar brand
of humor this was not the ability to see
oneself and see one's activities in a
detached and ironical spirit that would
have been fatal humor meant being
cheerful in the face of unpleasant
circumstances rallying the men's spirits
by laughing with them over some
slapstick incident submitting like a
good sport to an unjust punishment given
to oneself by the adjutant and laughing
about it afterwards in the mess this
conception of humor and obvious branch
of guts was in fact discretely designed
to counteract or totally extinguish any
tendencies towards an objective or
intellectual humor that might contain
tinges of satire or cynicism for such a
thing would have been detrimental to
another highly prized virtue that of
enthusiasm so this little brand of humor
comes out where there's nothing directed
with negativity up the chain of command
it's all just funny
and i don't
i think that's actually again maybe i'm
this the brainwashed dude here but i
think that the guts part is cool i think
that the dark humor twisted humor thing
is kind of cool too because there's
nothing better than getting
getting in shitty situations and being
able to laugh about it
i think that's cool
i guess maybe if you take it both these
things to this
far extreme
where we're not protesting anything
because we're just gonna laugh at it or
we're not gonna ever stop because we're
just going to keep going even if it's
going to be harmful to us or our troops
then it turns bad i guess
and he's got this word enthusiasm
enthusiasm i can hardly trust myself to
speak it seemed to mean a sort of blind
uncriminal uncritical application to any
task however silly or futile
that the neurosis or panic of superior
might have suddenly thrust upon us since
one of the points of enthusiasm that you
started doing whatever it was straight
away and without wasting time on
question enthusiasm could involve a
frantic expense of time and energy on
some trifling project wastefully because
uncritically undertaken abandoned
halfway as irrationally was it was as as
it was commenced this of course was just
what great soldiers of the past wished
to avoid when they deplored the
indiscriminate use of zeal why zeal
condemned alike by klaus fitz and
wellington
should now once again be thought
desirable it is interesting to speculate
so this idea of enthusiasm also known as
zeal is like hey i'm just on board for
whatever you tell me to do
and i guess that's another thing is it a
beautiful thing in many cases yes it is
but if you're getting told to charge the
machine gun nest and you go roger that
with enthusiasm and zeal and you get all
your guys killed that's not what we want
that shouldn't be what we want
maybe in world war one that's what we
quote wanted
but we shouldn't want that you should
want pushback
loyalty meant there's another term
loyalty loyalty meant that you were
required in the name of the queen in
honor of the regiment to conceal any
impatience or amusement you might feel
when the demands of your enthusiasm
became operatic far farcical or just
plain impossible of fulfillment loyalty
in fact was the conception often
blatantly used to blackmail you into
silence when you were faced with
incompetence and justice or to your
following of a superior officer that was
kind of funny
this is just loyalty dude where's your
loyalty bro he wants me to do this it
doesn't make any sense bro you need to
be more loyal
right
so she ability was also highly esteemed
at warminster
this like loyalty could mean
many good things such as hospitality and
the desire to please in social
intercourse but it also implied an
unquestioning deference to the
convenience and opinions of one's
military superiors so you're just going
to get on board with what everyone else
is saying
and you can see what we're doing we're
creating robots we're not creating
thinking people and this is bad
courage under fire a sort of distilled
essence of guts could not exactly be
taught so it had to be taken for granted
and all of us who were tacitly and
grimly assumed to possess it hence we
can pass to a very much boosted
commodity initiative
so we with now we finally go okay cool
we want to see initiative
unfortunately in the peacetime
conditions even for the most
part in wartime ones communications are
now so good that and the opportunities
for genuinely individual action so rare
that initiative tends to become a highly
contrived thing artificially fostered to
impress superiors
the sort of person who was praised at
warminster for initiative generally
turned out to be a meddlesome bully of
the type who reports to his best friend
or to his house master for immoral
behavior thereby himself becoming head
prefect in his friend's place
there you go
so
this section he gives a bunch of
examples of uh various types of these
officers and how they turned out
it seems fast forward a little bit it
seems that all remained of his training
in the mind of each recipient was the
faulty syllogism officer should be
gentlemen i am an officer
therefore i am a gentleman
after this
he seemed to behave neither as an
officer nor is a gentleman in generally
any accepted sense of these terms
and raven says this once an officer is
established in his own view as a member
of a superior and order giving classes
class he never loses this sense this is
where things turn into a nightmare right
so an officer is established
in his own view as a member of a
superior and order giving class
he never loses this sense but he can and
often does lose all awareness of the
moral basis of this superiority and all
the qualities which constitute this
basis so he forgets why he's in this
position he forgets that he was just
like placed here
he starts to believe his own [__]
and the [__] that's been fed to him
that people run around calling him sir
and saluting him
he just becomes
superior
as it were in vacuole which means in in
a vacuum he's in a vacuum he's just
superior
he becomes a gentleman when this happens
one gets that product so typical of the
british the amateur english officer
highly trained professional and
professionally and morally he has
forgotten his professional his pro his
professional techniques and sloughed off
in his sense of moral obligation but he
retained an unassailable sense of his
own superiority
and absolute right to give orders
my note next to that was nightmare
that's a nightmare
to forget how you ended up in this
position
to forget
that you don't know everything to just
get told that you're an officer and
you're superior
and you start to believe that this is a
nightmare for leadership
nowadays things are different the social
distance between officers and men more
often than not contrived rather than
rooted in their ancestry for officers of
humble origins this might well be
expected to produce sizeable problems of
adjustment the first jolt to their
social reinforcement standard will be of
one of the scripted discrepancy what's
interesting about this is
there's no guarantee
like i knew officers that came silver
spoon all day long and they were just
down to earth good people
and i also knew silver spoon officers
that thought that they deserved they
thought that they were superior
i also knew some guys from lower class
that scrambled through and scraped
through and became officers and they
were awesome
and they never forgot where they came
from and i also knew officers that had
come up through the ranks and they were
turds
leif points out that the best officer
that went through his junior officer
training
was a prior enlisted officer
and the worst officer that went through
his through his junior officer training
was a prior enlisted officer which is
crazy to think yeah
that's crazy to think i think that i
agree with that
your your description those four
categories whatever you want to call
them
same thing seeing the exact same thing
and i'm trying to remember the way you
were describing it is i remember
i guess i don't remember like the first
time it happened but
there's like a ceremony did do you do
you have a first salute ceremony
um
and i remember that being an incredibly
uncomfortable experience for me like
man this is weird the guy who i did it
was a good friend of mine who's enlisted
marine he had fought in desert storm
he was a a a known well well-known guy
and just by virtue of of um
accomplishing the criteria to make me an
officer like from one moment to the next
he saluted me yeah
and
i think i was just lucky to have that
sense of like man this is weird
you know
but also i think you described it well
like the reference for the institution
like this is how the institution is
designed and if you have that reverence
for it he didn't feel the mean and i
didn't feel superior
and yet that's the way it's supposed to
be and yeah and yet how easily i'm like
oh
i could get used to this you know how
quickly people fall into that trap of
fall into that trap
and it's not the institution that
bestowed this on me
yeah i deserve it i deserve it yes
yeah i mean and this again we're talking
about the military specifically but you
can apply this anywhere you apply this
anywhere oh well i you know i went to
this college i went through this program
i got my mba from here or there and all
of a sudden it's like oh
did i tell you that
did i mention where i went to college
you know it's like yeah that's cool man
appreciate it that's awesome
yeah but when you say it nobody notices
it
uh
there's a there's a note about this
raven's assessment so
somebody kind of read that big
assessment of
sandhurst and this guy says i read simon
raven's paper with great interest when
you when you ask for my comments you
must bear in mind that in 1898 when i
was gazetted
i joined a totally different type of
army
from that of today it was an
aristocratic army futile in the sense
that it was grounded on leadership and
fought and fellowship in which with few
exceptions the leaders were the sons of
gentlemen and more frequently than not
the eldest sons the most privileged sons
when i went to sandhurst we were not
taught to behave like gentlemen
because it never occurred to anyone that
we should behave otherwise
we were taught a lot of obsolete tactics
in every army that of that day did a
tremendous a lot of useless drill but
never heard a word about responsibility
loyalty guts etc because so i suppose
these were held to be the natural
prerequisites of gentlemen so this is
back in the day when it's like hey man
you better act like this you're
upholding the family name
the men
the followers of that period were a
rough lot simple tough illiterate
largely recruited from down and outs men
who had a lot met who met who had gotten
a lot of trouble vagabonds and a
sprinkling of the great sons and
grandsons sons of ncos and private
soldiers military families who generally
became ncos
there were therefore two distinct
classes really casts by birth on the
whole the men looked up to their
officers whether they were efficient or
insufficient or inefficient and the
officers did not look down on their men
why should they
so he was saying like this was just kind
of the way it was back then
the idea of an officer imposing on his
imposing his will on his men never
entered his head because one class was
so superior and the other so inferior
that it was unnecessary to do this there
wasn't even any opposing ideas to what
you were saying
the superior could not lose cast should
he play or mix with his men i remember
this is a good story i remember on my
first tour as an orderly officer on the
qms
was late for
the qms meeting the quartermaster so one
of the sailors was late for meat issue
and i thought he had risked it because i
was a novice
so i put him under arrest
when this was reported to the adjutant
he took me aside and said strictly
speaking you were right but actually
speaking you were an ass so don't do it
again and i didn't so he like punished
this guy trying to prove that he was
pretty said hey bro what are you doing
you technically you could do that but
that's not the way you treat your people
of the present-day democratic army i
know next to nothing
like the old aristocratic one it must
have its good points and is probably
more efficient but to me it is a folly
to try and mix the two a gentleman is
born and not made
it is probably true that it takes three
generations to fashion one and so it
would appear from mr raven's experiences
if you try and make them
synthetically you get neither an
aristocrat or a democracy one sees this
everywhere today among the rich the poor
on the roads in and in the factories i
repeat it again gentlemen are not turned
out like sausages they are turn they are
men of ingrained honor of principle and
of decent behavior and some of the
finest i have met in my long life have
belonged to the humblest classes
because this cast rather than class is
becoming extinct in my humble opinion
one of the great factors at the bottom
of the present world turmoil
and that's from uh jfc fuller and he's
another guy that was sort of in league
with um
liddell hart lots of great ideas
uh fought in north africa fought in
world war one or sorry in south africa
fought in world war one the nazis took a
bunch of his ideas and ran with them by
the way even though he's a brit
so
it's just a different i i wanted to read
that part because it's just a different
world it's just a different situation
and they caught sort of had this
pre-existing
system that was in place now what kind
of makes me disturbed about this is you
know
he's he's basically talking about how
great the gentlemen were of the day but
these were the gentlemen that freaking
acted like idiots leading their troops
to be killed
so there wasn't so much uh honor and
principle as he's talking about
uh closing out this section
he says from a general study of
leadership it seems there is much in
military organizations to invite
incompetence officers are selected for
the wrong reasons required to fulfilling
incompatible roles
and expected to function adequately in a
communication system of dubious
efficiency
at higher levels of command they are
protected from adverse criticism by
their invisibility
and by the plain fact that in times of
stress even the poorest leaders like
drunken fathers and rabbit's feet are
clung to with pathetic if misplaced
dependency
yeah the invisibility part he mentioned
that
and was talking about the fact that
uh
a lot of these senior leaders they just
no one would see him you wouldn't see
him on the front lines so they weren't
getting any criticism because they were
they weren't around to be criticized
military achievement besides providing
legitimate outlets for aggression
the gratification of obsessive
tendencies and reassurances about
virility
armies and navies also cater for another
basic human motive the need to achieve
they do this in several ways they embody
related hierarchies of rank money and
class so there's another thing that you
can get by joining the military if
you're a person that's driven to succeed
you can go in the military and you can
get like a a formatted way to move up
the chain of command
second they accentuate the challenge of
promotional ladder by making certain
upward movements very difficult indeed
third the ethos of the armed forces is
such that such as to make advancement
laudable and highly rewarding generals
have every advantage bar that of age
over those lower down on the ladder they
are richer safer and more comfortable
their chances of collecting honors
orders and knight hoods are imminently
greater than those
of more junior ranks finally even the
most modest thirst for achievement is
encouraged by training and convention
the taboo on junior speaking to senior
seniors in officer training
establishments saluting and being
saluted orders of march rules as to say
as who says sir to whom all serve to
emphasize the horizontal stratifications
of military organizations
besides adding luster to each new level
gained
so that's what the military sets up this
really nice place where you can kind of
you see what the game is and if you know
how to play the game you're gonna get
you're gonna get satisfaction
unfortunately there are aspects of
military career which are unlikely to
attract people with high achievement
motivation
and he says this at first sight these
arguments would seem to suggest that the
possibility of promotion in a military
organization would attract those with a
potential for achievement go-getters
entrepreneurs innovators and men with
energy and drive in short people who
would make first-class military
commanders right so you think oh cool
this is like a hierarchy set up that
makes sense i'm down i want to go in
there because i'm an entrepreneur i'm a
go-getter
sometimes it does in the case of
wellington montgomery rommel and zhukov
men with inordinately strong needs for
achievement all those guys wanted to do
well
unfortunately however there are aspects
of a military career which are unlikely
to attract people with high achievement
motivation the fact that traditionally
promotion depends upon seniority class
wealth conformity and obedience may well
leave them rather cold neither means nor
the ends are sufficiently attractive so
when you get a guy like wellington like
rommel
they look and say okay how do i need to
get promoted oh i've got to conform i've
got to be a yes man so all their
entrepreneurial spirit is thrown out the
window
they don't they they're being forced to
comply in order to get promoted so it
doesn't really seem as attractive as
they thought it originally was going to
be
moreover military types
military has never smiled upon
entrepreneurs and innovators the cut and
thrust of private enterprise cleverness
and even working too hard
have not been deemed good form there is
however another class of person for whom
the military might well be an attractive
proposition these are people who
achievement motivation is pathological
in origin
the crucial difference between the two
sorts of achievement the healthy and the
pathological
may be summarized by saying
that whereas the first is buoyed up by
hopes of success
the second is driven by fear of failures
you got one person that wants to do a
good job
and one person that's just scared to
fail
whereas the former achieves out of a
quest of excellence in his job the
latter achieves by any means available
not necessarily because of any sincere
devotion to the work but because of the
status social promotion or social
approval and reduction of doubts about
the self that such achievement brings
applying these distinctions to the
military would seem that senior
commanders fall into two groups
and i think this is actually pretty
accurate those primarily concerned with
improving their professional ability and
those primarily concerned with
self-betterment
[Laughter]
fast forward a little bit research
suggests that these two sorts of
achievement motivation go along with
certain other personality traits
thus need achievement motivation towards
professional excellence is accompanied
by greater occupational and intellectual
competence so this is a person that want
to get promoted for the right reasons
greater occupational and intellectual
competence that's what he wants a better
memory for uncompleted tasks and
therefore a predisposition to finish
something once it's begun a preference
when choosing working partners for
successful strangers rather than
unsuccessful friends that's what's just
the crappy leaders always surround
themselves with their crappy
unsuccessful friends
a great greater readiness to volunteer
for psychological experiments greater
activity in the institution or community
of which they are a member
so this is
i i think it's just important to
remember that there's some people that
are out there for themselves
and there's some people that are out
there to try and do a good job he says
compare lawrence this is lawrence of
arabia compare lawrence roughing it with
his tiny arab force on the 800-mile trek
across the desert to west
to to rest akaba from the turks
with townsend
comfortably a sconce in his villa on the
sea of
marmara while his captured troops died
in their thousands from exposure
malnutrition and brutality
the contrast in both cases
is between the self-imposed asceticism
of high achievement motivation and the
self-indulgence of one concerned with
professional excellence
less concerned with professional
excellence than with personal advantage
pretty good stark
difference between those two
how is it that some of the criteria for
promotion to military organizations are
evidently such as to favor people with a
pathological degree of achievement
motivation this is scary
the person that might have a tendency to
get promoted is the one that's looking
out for themselves in some cases in the
military again it's important to say
this isn't like the entire military but
certainly i certainly saw people in the
military that were 100 looking out for
themselves and they got promoted yeah
that does happen yeah there's no doubt
about it it it happens less than you
would think
a lot of times that transparency that
these idiots would have looking out for
themselves and trying to make those
maneuvers everyone would see it and
they'd be like no you're not getting
promoted
but it did happen
there are grounds for thinking that
incompetent commanders tend to be those
whom the need to avoid failure exceeds
the urge to succeed
according to jw atkinson and nt feather
such people tend to eschew activities
which they may show up in a poor light
and unless forced to do so refrain from
taking on any skilled task where there
are any doubts about the outcome so
people
that are just concerned about themselves
they'll only go into jobs where they
know they're going to win
that's what they're trying to do they're
just they're they're only doing jobs of
things that they know they're going to
do they know that they're going to win
at
herein lies a special dilemma though
they need to achieve
it is the very nature of trying which
exposes them to that which they fear
most failure
they are like people who try to climb
mountains
out of an underlying fear of heights
it would not be surprising to find that
such people are attracted to and prosper
in the armed services for if one plays
it carefully in the military in contrast
to the world of commerce offers
achievement without tears stick to the
rule book do nothing while explicit
approval from the next higher up always
confirm form never offend your superiors
and you will float serenely if a trifle
slowly upward a blimp in both senses of
the word
that's the reality you can't you there
you can do that
you can join the military and you can
just kind of keep your nose clean stay
low profile don't take any additional
risks
conform and you will get promoted over
time in many cases marine corps is
tighter though i think
i'd like to think that i mean you're
described what you're describing i can
i'm
he's right yeah and i've seen it
and not not right in a blanket statement
no no no but it certainly happens yes
yeah yeah no correct and and you're
right in saying like that's part of the
system is is you have you might show for
this altruism of how it works and the
wrong people get promoted sometimes now
it's not a lot of those people it's
actually a small number like you said
but it happens enough that you will see
it you're not going to go a career and
go oh i never saw that every single time
it was the right person of the right
reasons no throughout my career there
was examples that i can reflect back on
it's a small number but the system
doesn't work perfectly and
i think the thing i was thinking about
and this is military i think in general
there are enough jobs in the military
that have been done enough times that
the template is there that you go i can
take those head orders and like man
it's really low risk you know i'm gonna
eat cutter the cookie cutter job that's
been done and take the template jack's
gonna head off to me here's the you know
here's the script follow the script low
profile
um low risk you're gonna look good in
the end and you're going to get promoted
there there are those jobs out there
i was lucky in my career
to have jobs that either had never been
done before or really there wasn't a lot
of history behind them so
you know i'm remembering a couple times
like when i was in command of an
organization where you know i was being
told hey um
hey if this fails it's gonna destroy the
whole thing like oh that's uh okay okay
that's awesome i think i've told the
story before i'm far enough away from it
now that i can i can tell it if i
haven't before but when i took over the
first f-35 squadron uh the marine corps
f-35 program was on probation like they
were contemplating canceling the f-35
for the marine corps the b variant which
was the marine corps variant and the
marine corps already long since
committed to that was the only platform
there was no plan b there was no
alternative to that so if we were going
to lose the f-35b the marine corps was
going to lose tack air
and
as soon as i took command and you know i
stood up i told you there's a guy there
before no airplanes but when i took
command the airplane started to arrive
right when i got there the comrade of
the marine corps came down
um
spent like an hour with me they met him
at the squadron was he in a storage
major and me and my sergeant major and
he goes hey i hate to tell you this
but you can't crash an airplane oh like
wow that's
oh
roger that roger that you know what i
mean like if you crash an airplane we're
gonna lose the program marino's gonna
lose that care
and so you're talking about the the
balance of the risk of losing is a lot
you know the balance that between the
benefit of winning like i'll just you
know marginal benefit of winning but
like there's zero risk or you know the
flip side is hey if i go two years as a
squadron commander everything goes great
i'm gonna get a firm handshake and a
congratulations and life's going to go
on but nobody's going to credit me for
doing anything remarkable because the
system is the the program is just moving
along where it needs to go but if i
screwed up
you know that downside risk and and i
understand the
the aversion to that like hey would you
rather have a guaranteed win with you
know a guaranteed marginal win with no
chance of losing
or
high
risk of failure
but this is a once in a lifetime thing
that would need the right person at the
right time to go through that a lot of
people are reversed to that yep well and
this is the other scary thing about that
is
so you're the squadron commander you get
told don't crash any birds
well
how about we fly a little less yes right
you said that because in the exact same
weekend the
deputy commandant for aviation the head
aviator the marine corps
said your number one job is to fly as
much as humanly possible damn roger that
okay
and listen there's a part of it too that
you have to understand this like
there is nothing that i could do
personally short of shutting down the
squadron right to guarantee that we
don't care there's nothing i can do that
so
there's a part of that like if you can
just let that go just recognize my best
chance of me being successful is to
micromanage none of this yeah as opposed
to trying to macromanage all of it yeah
you know and that's such a good point
because
okay we can either
fly as little as humanly possible which
means everyone's paranoid no one really
knows how to do their job very like all
right we're going to fly these things
we'll be awesome at it and that's the
right call obviously not everyone would
make that decision and even then they're
still even the right call doesn't
guarantee the outcome you can do
everything right and you know what yeah
you have a mishap on me those air traps
yes yeah things break yeah things
breaking mid-flight yep that happens
they do especially brand new airplanes
they're still being designed while
you're flying them those things happen
how many f-35s have crashed
not a lot so
i believe i have to go back and look i
think the first one crashed in my
squadron like six months after i left
um yeah got out of it
um
we've there's been a very small
it's been a very safe airplane what does
an f35 cost
at the time it was 130 million now it's
probably 90.
oh so they cut the price down a little
bit well those first ones are like you
know they were literally the very first
ones off the assembly line so that that
as you know like that mass production
benefit hadn't kicked in yet so age one
was kind of like a unique article now
like they're jamming them out they're
making a bunch of them and it's it's
more cost effective i know these are
crazy numbers but at the time they were
they were expensive
133 a copy i had 14. if you
when you're flying an f-35 and you're
doing a vertical how how often did you
do a vertical takeoff
uh
like a short take off like the stovall
like the yeah like yeah like a hairier
yeah
not that often
sometimes it's how much gas do you go
through taking one of those things off
vertically
the vertical flying burns a ridiculous
amount of gas you just basically have to
refuel as soon as you get up it's not
that bad but it's it's a lot of gas yeah
the the landings are more of a critical
because you're on the clock like you
come in you got to be relatively light
you can't land like a fully loaded
airplane vertically because it's too
heavy okay so you got to be like at a
certain limited amount of gas so the
plane is light enough to hover
but then again like you can't just you
know sit there all day long because you
don't have that much gas it's nothing
like the harrier was those guys it was
sketchy like really really sketchy
but um yeah you're burning a lot of gas
a lot it was sketchy in a hairier what
made it more sketchy um less powerful
airplane harder to fly less margin for
air less you needed less gas to be able
to land and didn't have as much time you
know just
i feel like i flew the uh harrier
simulator out at yuma yeah dude i
crashed that thing literally 17 times in
a row my total flight time was nine
seconds or something
if you got into an f35 right now in the
simulator i could over the shoulder walk
you through it you landed
almost perfectly the first try
well that's like drones
man those first drones came out that
were like little model airplanes guys
were just crashing them everywhere and
now a three-year-old can fly a drone and
that's that's no exaggeration yeah
technology uh this thing says
on the same note
the net result would be a bimodal
distribution of officers at every grade
so these two different types of officers
you end up with them at every grade
those who take risks and get away with
it the montgomeries and lawrences of
this of this world and those who have
plotted up the hard but safe way the
good old boys who never speak out a turn
who make up intact and conformity what
they lack in enterprise and initiative
interesting
contemplation of a nept commander
suggests that
they were of the latter genre in the
first place they were renowned almost
without exception for being
hypersensitive to criticism so those
people that are the the the conformists
hypersensitive
ask the question of physical bravery in
no way detracts from the feats of
courage to note that the fear of being
afraid the fear of social disapproval
for cowardice and most important the
personal shame attendant upon flinching
in the face of danger could drive a man
to perform acts of valor far beyond the
normal call of duty this is not to deny
that bravery occurs for other reasons
out of pure altruism or patriotism
but merely that some individuals are so
lacking in self-esteem that they will
gladly exchange the fear of failure for
their own physical destruction
that's kind of a weird thing to say
in a very real sense military
organizations recognize and trade upon
this fact of human nature death rather
than dishonor is no empty platitude but
formulates an essential and ancient
feature of military i'll tell you what's
oh
i think that's a weird thing to say but
i think what if he would expand a little
bit more which he doesn't what's scary
about that is when people are
being brave
with other people's lives that that's
what's jacked up look if you're brave
and you go and do something heroic good
on you i don't care what your motivation
was i think sam harris always talks
about the fact that you can't
you can't fake bravery right you run out
in the street there's no faking it you
did it right and that's that
it doesn't matter if you thought you
were did it because you were gonna be
uh ashamed or you did it because you
were just hyper motivated or whatever it
doesn't matter you can't fake it you
were brave no no no question about it
but when you start being brave with
other people's lives that's a freaking
disaster and that's what these horrible
leaders end up doing
it cannot be emphasized too strongly
that this suggested relationship between
valor and the need to prove oneself in
no way debases bravery on the contrary
it takes the view that the best measure
of courage is the fear that is overcome
then these were the bravest of them all
froze only by conquering rational fear
that they could nullify fear of being
afraid so there you go
the tragedy of this issue is that
if military organizations select their
senior commanders for their physical as
opposed to moral bravery they not only
might ignore other equally important
attributes but are bound to select a
proportion of individuals whose
underlying psychopathology is quite
unfitted to positions of high command
in this way they invite incompetence so
just because someone's brave doesn't
mean you want to put them in a
leadership position it doesn't say you
don't want him there and there is
certainly a huge benefit to someone
that's been in combat
and knows what's happening knows the
understands the emotions and
and the the human nature that takes
place on the front lines for sure that's
highly beneficial shouldn't be the only
reason you select somebody though
the last trait of those who harbor a
fear of failure concerns the selection
of subordinates
they're really two components to this
process the first concern is the way an
individual sees himself in comparison
with his competitors in the second the
way he thinks others will see him in
comparison with his contemporaries in
either case he may wait try he may well
try to elevate his own self estimation
by choosing a low standard with which to
make comparison
hence the phenomenon of people who tend
to shun the company of individuals more
gifted and even choose workmates as
selected or select as subordinates
people who may consider inferior to
themselves what a freaking disaster that
is so that's the person that wants to
look good so hires a bunch of idiots
he talks a little bit about hague he
talks about hague being painfully aware
of his limitations hey was the world war
one commander of british troops and then
uh
tried to enter the one profession open
to the dunce of the family the army only
to find that even there he failed to
shine he got put in his position the
reason he got promoted is because he got
sort of a
a hook up from a family member his elder
sister henrietta knew the duke of
cambridge hooked him up with entering
his staff college then he was the aide
to camp
to the king
dude this guy's just
making moves making moves
became respected for his conventional
opinions
that's crazy right you become respected
because you agree with everybody that's
a great point king that's a 100 right
king
he said things like cavalry will have a
larger sphere of action in future wars
artillery only seems to be really
effective against raw troops these are
just idiotic statements
uh he also had a he was also uh prone to
a steady denigration of his competitors
and the removal of his superior ki
of superior commanders this guy was just
a [__] talker hague
haig's talent for finding fault with
everybody but himself was particularly
keen
whenever results had resulted in
military setback and he gives all these
just
crazy examples
uh
he put he blamed someone he's unfit to
command a division at this critical
period of the operations in france and
should only be employed at home by the
way there's people that are working for
him by the way
ralston is unsatisfactory loyalty to his
subordinates but he has many other
valuable qualities he's trying to get
rid of somebody he's like he has
volleyball qualities but he's overly
loyalty to his troops
it seems impossible to discuss the
military problems with and with an
unreasoning brand of his kind
the fact is that sir john seems
uncapable of realizing the nature of the
fighting that has been going on and the
difficulties of getting fresh troops and
stores forward in adequate communication
trenches doug on saturday october 9th he
made an impromptu report to oh this is
uh on saturday october 4th 9th hague
this guy makes this report up his chain
of command about the his commander
sir john french
what happens eventually french gets
fired who gets put in charge hague
hey got his wish reaching the pinnacle
of the greatest army that the empire had
ever put in the field
in the past or was ever to amass in the
future a body whose heroism and devotion
was such that they could twice in two
successive years be ravaged and hopeless
offensive who were in a single day to
lose more men than any other army in the
history of the world whom after 27
months of slaughter and exhaustion he
was to leave so periously exposed that
they were nearly annihilated
just
horrible
and this uh section that we'll close out
with for today
says
freedom of expression
and cognitive process unfettered by
inhibitions were not looked upon with
favor in military personnel
so
that's a horrible situation
it seems then that in the case of
achievement motivation
as with obsessive tendency military
organizations attract and then reinforce
those very characteristics which will
prove antithetical to competent military
performance
it's a
again is that true in the military yes
it is is it true in the civilian or let
me rephrase that i saw your look on your
face dave can it be true in the military
yes it can can it attract people with
these type of tendencies yes it can can
it then
provide opportunities for people to sort
of just get on board with the system yes
it can does the civilian sector do that
as well hell yes it does happens in any
leadership situation
where
we take these things that we should be
striving for like freedom of expression
and unfettered cognitive processes
meaning you should just be able to think
and we crush them
and you know i was thinking this uh
we've been talking about the the
the eo leadership loop and included in
that is the is the ooda loop right these
ideas of constantly running through your
mind
all these different aspects of
leadership
and the main lesson that you and i are
putting out this is what we've just put
out at the muster the main lesson when
you're running these loops is not to get
stuck
is not to get stuck is to free your mind
and that's how i close out the last
podcast i said free your mind
and i want to reiterate that you have to
keep your mind open if your mind's
always stuck even it can be stuck by so
many different things it can be stuck by
your ego your insecurities it can be
stuck by your fear it can be stuck by
tradition it can be stuck by custom it
can be stuck by the restraints of the
institution that you're in if your mind
is getting stuck like that you have to
be weary
you have to be
afraid of that because if you let your
mind get stuck in that
fixed position
you're gonna get flanked you're gonna
get overrun and you're gonna get
destroyed and if you're in a leadership
position
that is what's going to happen not just
to you
but to your troops
so keep an open mind
echo charles yes sir what do you got
the that whole that part about like not
taking risks uh fear of failure like
that kind of stuff like for whatever
reason
it was making me think of like the jiu
jitsu
journey ascending with like getting
belts and all this stuff so in the
beginning
yeah sure a little of mine specific but
you can kind of see it where
you know if you're focused on the belt
yeah you you tend to be more like fear
of failure kind of approach to training
and
but if you're just like hey i'm in here
to get better and learn and be humble
take risks see what happens all this
stuff compete in st you know and the
higher you get the better you'll become
yeah but
if you start let's say
you get like i don't know purple belt i
feel like is one of the the benchmark
builds right which kind of become
that's like jujitsu puberty right there
you know
so a lot of people and it can vary from
belt to belt for sure but sometimes
they'll be like oh well i don't want to
look bad as a purple belt so i'm going
to take less risk i'm going to only
train with guys who
i know that i won't you know do poorly
against or whatever you know and you can
kind of fall into that trap but then you
get people who they don't they don't
think about that kind of stuff it's like
the belt that's just a byproduct of of
my journey and i don't even think about
that those are the guys that just keep
getting better and better yeah yeah i i
i thought you were actually going to
bring up just like the entrepreneurial
spirit and
you know we work with a lot of companies
in excellent front and the leaders that
have taken risk and have broken outside
the norm those are the leaders that they
end up doing exceptionally
well right if they manage it well like
look you can take big risks you can fail
right that happens
that's why they're called risks
but
if you want to look can you play it safe
yeah yes you can
and you can do that in the corporate
world but hey you can you can follow the
rules and you can do you can and you can
move up the chain and that's fine that's
fine
if you want to excel you're gonna have
to take some chances you're gonna have
to take some risks that's what you're
gonna have to do
and
and and then you do if you do utilize
sort of the
the standard sort of conformity to move
up the chain
what i will i
okay i get it but you know what don't
suppress
don't suppress risk from others don't
don't
don't suppress entrepreneurial thinking
from other people inside your
organization that's where i think we run
into a real problem you know i kind of
followed the rules and conformed
and i got my promotion and then dave
comes along and he's a little bit more
of a risk-taker a little bit more
entrepreneurial and this could be in the
military this could be in the business
sector and what do i do i outrank him i
shut him down i partially shut him down
because i don't want him i don't want
him to out out maneuver me so i'm just
going to shut down all his ideas
i'm also going to shut him down because
i don't want to take any risk so
if you wanna
if you wanna play that game for yourself
and you don't wanna take a bunch of
risks and you just wanna have a safe
comfortable job that's okay that's not
bad
look if you work hard and and and you do
a good job inside your business
organization that's great i i actually
like that i appreciate it
but the minute you you have that
attitude and you start to impose it on
people around you you need to check
yourself you need to check yourself
because you're shutting down mind your
closing minds and you're really in the
long term hurting your organization
you ever come across a situation it
feels like it feels like it's real
common where you get two people that go
into business together
one guy's risk averse one guy is like
freaking try anything and they sort of
start to balance each other out for sure
and not to mention there's some jobs
that are kind of more conducive for
certain attitude types right the risky
guys like out doing the sales pitch and
the other guys back in the account
balance in the books yeah yeah yeah yeah
so it is good to have business partners
like that for sure yeah kind of reel you
in when you need it as long as they're
not overbearing i guess right there you
go
there you go
all right well
we're trying to keep our minds open yes
we're trying to improve ourselves
mentally physically
you know the whole nine yards
echo you got any suggestions yeah we do
i do we do we all do actually we know
you want to go
no i just want to make sure we're
recording oh
jack
that was good thanks dave by the way so
what do you got echo charles what do you
got for us
uh well you know we're all working out
doing jiu jitsu i guess you know
hopefully we should be i'm just saying
you know it's one of those things it
does to keep you on the path
uh we're reading mental physical
everything right we want to lead by
example i'll tell you that
you want to make good decisions i'll
tell you that
so
all right well on this path we're on
this path good decisions physical
capability
mental capability we'll say in a
nutshell it's what it is yes and
improvement
yes we want to take risks but not too
many risks check we want to take risks
but not too big of risks okay concur
yeah so one thing you don't want to risk
is your health i'll tell you that right
now
it's a bad thing to risk when did you
write that little set up right there i
just came up
speaking of mental acuity look at you
look at that guy hey well
anyway you said all that stuff just to
say we don't take too many risks with
our health there you go it's just a tiny
bit it's true if you don't have it all
together man i'm just saying it's
freaking impressive it's not the thing
to take risks with hell yeah hell yeah
thanks
for the support choco um okay so we got
energy drinks that was mine
we got energy drinks not old school
energy drinks that do risk your health
we have energy drinks that don't risk
your health that actually improve your
health improve your health no risk
upside across the board across the board
no gambling here upside across the board
yes right if i was to say hey this thing
over here can make you feel good yeah
and you were like okay cool
and it and not only can it make you feel
good it can actually make you be more
healthy
what would you say to that i'd say cool
that'd you say cool what if i had
something else over here i was like this
will also make you feel good for a
little bit
and you said okay that sounds good but
then i said after that you're going to
be addicted to it and you're going to
end up becoming a crystal
methamphetamine addict and dying
yes that would be bad that's downside
yes sir that's downside so we like the
little we like that little height that
we got
from the crystal meth that y that i gave
you sure but then the downside is like a
disaster your teeth are falling out you
lost your job there's all kinds of
problems in the future
that is true yes so i'm not gonna sell
you that no i'm not gonna want you to
take that you're not gonna recommend
that you're correct but i've got
something else over here yes sir it's
gonna give you the hype yes with zero
downside all hype zero downside and this
is i will not find you at a
you know a meth lab licking the floor no
which is what i'm afraid of
if i give you the other thing that is an
undesirable outcome yes sir
so yes so when you're choosing energy
drink you're looking for energy drink
even if not even into energy drinks
necessarily and i understand if you're
not because really how could you be when
you consider those yes
yes now we got a solution for that yeah
straight up all healthy energy drink
completely good for you jackal
discipline go yeah bye
it's a good one
tastes good too different flavors
so for the apparently on paper
the more popular one is orange
afterburner orange afterburner orange
dave burke good deal dave's signature
flavor on paper that's good this makes
sense you know like if you don't know if
you're not in the know you go you you
have a awesome selection you know you
know that the orange is going to come
through
wouldn't you agree
yes yeah i feel the same way i feel the
same way but you want to take a little
bit more risk
right
maybe maybe a higher upside maybe bring
in the threat
i don't know i don't know i'm just a
person but hey
maybe though you take a little bit more
risk on a more exotic flavor like mango
mango passion fruit to be specific
you might wind up with that bigger
upside i don't know that's up to you but
nonetheless there are many different
flavors you choose whichever one all of
them are all outside no downside so it
doesn't matter technically at the end of
the day what flavor you choose that's
for your own personal choice
so get some of that
discipline go we also got joint warfare
krill oil we got the discipline powder
we got some new um what what do you call
hype all right well they're not
technically called hype i think they're
called pre-workout uh
mixes powders
so so we've had the discipline powder
for a while just called discipline
and it didn't have much caffeine in it
to be real specific
and people were like hey that's cool we
appreciate it
but sometimes we want more of a kick
so
we didn't go nuts we didn't go 700
milligrams of caffeine yeah do you know
the
numbers 95 95 per scoop oh okay okay per
scoop that okay so that's that's more
moderate i would say oh
it's moderate unless you have two scoops
or three scoops right which is good
because okay the the classic pre-workout
um if you go two scoops that's too much
already it's it's too much yeah but at
the same time if you don't want to get
all nuts with it you got to start
meticulously putting only a little bit
of powder you can't really bend you know
so i dig it so yeah that that makes
sense put if you need 300 milligrams of
caffeine before one workout if that's
what you need i'm not i'm not hey dig it
man i dig it
but you just have three scoops yeah i
would say back off a little bit
that's my personal generally speaking
but here's the thing also do some
abstinence days right yeah yes like on
the weekend you know whatever on monday
whatever some days be like yeah i'm not
gonna have any at all yeah any caffeine
at all generally speaking i feel like
that's a good move anyway to not go
every single day or whatever like give
yourself a break or whatever and that
way you'd maximize the effects
anyway that's what i'm talking about yes
sir i think you're right about that but
you've never really been that hardcore
because let's face it a pre-workout
it gives you like a bigger pump yeah no
i've
pre-workout really isn't my thing yeah
the only unless you count jujitsu as a
workout which we've had this discussion
lately that's not really a workout but
like i would have disciplined
powder before going to the jujitsu right
and i still will do that
but
if as far as i'm concerned rolling in
with a freaking pump in heart i'm not
really down for that
and that's
typically that's not why we take
pre-workout too for workouts like
jiu-jitsu
i i consider you just a workout that's a
hard workout actually it's harder to
work out technically as far as output
goes most of the time more than your
average or other workout depending on
the workout obviously but let's say if
you're going in you're going to do
eight sets of 12
with some bench and then maybe some
tricep extensions curls this kind of
thing you take a pre-workout bro that's
that's the jam you're saying that's it
huh so we made one of these for people
like echo charles that wants to get
it's uh discipline go powder yeah
available now you know
by the way yeah you get some mango other
flavors milk if you need some protein
tastes like dessert one of the best
things that have ever been invented i'm
expecting but probably
do they have a nobel prize for dessert
[Music]
no really i don't think they have a
nobel prize for protein shakes uh well
yeah you know not that i'm aware there
should be let's face it there should be
one yes and actually more than you know
really because they like okay you know
you heard of people making like mulch
pancakes and all this stuff okay here's
the jam keep this in mind do this
milkshake
frozen banana that whole jam the whole
creaminess thanks tulsi all day right so
so make make that when the kids aren't
looking then you buy those little uh
popsicle what do you call
photons yeah that you can make popsicles
in
and you make popsicles
then you tell the kids hey i have a
surprise for you after dinner you guys
eat all your dinner all good right i
have a surprise like oh cool they're all
excited you bust out that pop it looks
like one of those pudding pops you see
him saying so that's what you've been
doing no i'm gonna do it
yeah but if you're saying that's a good
idea
all right that's the nobel prize running
monk uh white jocko white t by the way
you can get the stuff you can get the
drinks at wawa you can get the stuff at
vitamin shop or you can get it from
jackalful.com if you subscribe to any of
it you get free shipping which is a
which is a total bonus oh yeah and you
don't got to remember to take all that
stuff so it's all good also
origin usa this is american-made stuff
products goods
jeans boots american-made denim man
doesn't get much
american-made than that
you could just say american american but
it's sad that the american iconic genes
that you have aren't even made in
america not you but i mean us we as a
nation a lot of people are out there
wearing jeans they think are made in
america yeah they're not made in america
they're um they're pitched yeah they're
they might be packaged in america but
really there's communists that are
making your genes
and there's nothing against the people
but the government has those people
enslaved
so we we're not for that we're against
that you're against that you know i saw
you compete on the news the other day oh
yeah you guys look good
it's doing your thing yeah
we're out there yes sir um it's worthy
story yeah i think so this is this we're
bringing manufacturing back to america
you got to tell some of those guys to
stop jamming up your name bro
i just uh maybe i should i don't know
they call me jocko will nick will yeah
willie nick
willa nick will nick
i don't know i don't like that i feel
like it i don't like it either i feel
like i
do i take offense to it
maybe maybe not but i feel like they're
kind of pronouncing my name wrong it's
weird that you would do that it says
will inc that's literally what it says
yes how you reverse those numbers and
reverse those letters and stuff i don't
know but that's what happens and i don't
know you start to wonder have you have
they not heard anyone else say your name
ever yeah it's strange it is odd right
kind of strange but there you go either
way either way you look good you were
saying some great stuff american uh back
to origin usa yeah everything is made in
in america the seeds that are grown into
the cotton that goes into the loom to
make the material the denim that makes
the jeans oh man oh here made in america
yeah boom and since we are doing jiu
jitsu you can get an american made
jiu-jitsu key it's true
very true also yeah a lot of cool stuff
on there origin usa.com that's where you
can get it also jaco has a store it's
called jocko store it's a good spot good
spot you want to represent on this path
that we're all on
discipline equals freedom
that that goes deep if you want to
represent boom that's where you can get
your shirts and hats t-shirts um
hoodies some rash guards on there some
other cool stuff on there there's a jiu
jitsu section now apparently yes sir
there is i thought i'm gonna represent
the other day represents hard jiu jitsu
is like jiu-jitsu
you look good it looked good on them
jack daniel hill had one on top oh jack
daniel they know yes
there's a dean lister shirt coming out
too at some point yeah oh the the foot
shirt the foot sure yeah that's freaking
lovely also uh we have what's called the
shirt locker
it's a subscription service you get a
you get a cool new shirt every month
some good stuff coming out the christmas
shirt coming out oh
oh yeah that's a legit shirt you showed
it to me
that's so freaking that's a freaking
legit shirt solid that's a legit shirt i
felt the same way that's a legit shirt
it's uh can we say that or is it like
that what if you say what it is
oh yeah yeah no yeah you can say it it's
just uh it's a christmas shirt and it
has the christmas truth 1914
christmas truce 1914. yep we got the
flags of the nations involved it's
freaking legit
respect
respect oh yeah big time but yeah so
yeah the shirt locker it's um like i
said subscription you get a cool new
shirt uh every month a lot a lot of good
feedback on that one and we're tight and
we actually tightened it up a lot too
because we're you know how it's anyway
it can be complicated to to provide that
so
i feel like all the
issues there weren't huge issues but
it's real tightened up it's a good
streamlined process now so keep that in
mind
jack jackostore.com make sure you can
get this stuff uh subscribe to this
podcast too
don't forget about jocko unraveling with
daryl cooper the grounded podcast a
warrior kid podcast also we have jocko
underground.com
and what that is is a little alternative
world that we created just in case this
world goes sideways we don't control
these platforms that you're listening on
right now
so if something were to go sideways we
might get banned for talking about
masculine and feminine characteristics i
don't know could be some people are
sensitive to that kind of thing even
though we're reading a book from 1976
it just doesn't matter these days so if
that should happen we are in our own
place cost eight dollars and eighteen
cents a month if you can't afford that
email
assistance at jockowunderground.com
and we make another sort of tangential
podcast to talk about stuff on that one
as well life advice yeah a lot of q a
life advice from jocko straight up yeah
that's straight up
uh we have a youtube channel
on the ad assistant director and if you
want to see quality assistant directing
you can just go subscribe to that
because you can sense
how i make those special calls critical
calls very influential you know it's
that last
you know like you're lifting and you get
to
you get to deadlift
495. it takes a lot of work to get that
last little bit right sure
you're trying to cut your run time down
it takes a lot you get to you know a
certain spot then it takes a lot of work
to get that
it's real easy for you
because you get to a certain spot and
then i just roll in as the assistant
director and just kind of go next level
for you right so like how like like
muhammad ali right when he they'd be
like oh how many sit-ups do you do he's
like i don't know how many sit-ups i do
because i only count i only start
counting when it starts to hurt right so
i get all the easy sit-ups and you roll
in when it hurts and and bring us past
the finish line there you go if you want
to check that out you can subscribe to
my youtube channel thank you hell yeah
also psychological warfare is like an
album that we made back in the day for
fundamental weaknesses that mental
weaknesses that that we may
stumble onto before we do workouts
before we
freaking cheat on our diet eat some
stuff that we don't want to be eating
nonetheless these are moments of
weakness
that jocko helps us through well you can
just listen to that he'll tell you why
you should just stand up stay on the
path yeah it's going to be better for
you chocolate tells you why it's a good
one also if you want to hang some cool
stuff on your wall flipsidecanvas.com
dakota meyer
that's his company he's making cool
uh graphic things to hang on your wall
got a bunch of books final spin dave
burke
what do you got coming it's out it's out
it's out this is it that's right it's
live
finally what do you think's gonna what
do you think the reviews are gonna say
what's your review
people know my review i think i've
talked about it my review is good i
think the mass review is going to be
good
i i have a personal interest in this one
because this is one of the few times
you shared with me i think
i think i might have been way up there
one of the first people to see this yep
and i
i don't like i don't i don't take
positions all that often and my position
was immediately like this is going to be
awesome and my validation for that
wasn't what i thought of it is i gave it
to my wife and she read the whole thing
straight through yeah and i'm like bro
i think i said something like really
flippant like trust me or like
i know or words that i don't like to use
and i was like dug into media like bro
trust me yeah something along those
lines so we're here at that moment of
truth i'm pretty sure now that's going
to play out i'll tell you okay so my in
my family
not only my immediate family meaning my
willing but also my
mother father sisters
there's not a lot of
cheerleading happening you're not
getting a bunch of compliments ever
in fact
it's the opposite like we're going to
look for the holes we're going to look
for the freaking the the issues the
problems whatever
and that's what we're going to hone in
on
so i gave this book to my oldest
daughter she was one of the first people
to read it and i gave her like a paper
copy like i printed it out here you go i
said hey read this
uh i was actually just i just said hey
can you proofread this for me you know
she's in college at the time i said hey
you know proofreading find any whatever
errors
so she's got a red pen now
and she reads it
and she gets done
and she comes walking out of her room
because she was home at home even though
she was in college because of miss rona
you know everyone was shut down so she
was there
and she comes walking out of her room
and uh
she's like i go oh you know oh you
finished and she's like yeah just so
nonchalant just so like whatever like so
you're an idiot
and i said um how was it
she goes oh this is fine like literally
just shining me on
and i go oh cool because i know what's
happening you know i know there's no way
she's gonna be like this was awesome
i go oh well
what you know what parts of it did you
like or whatever
and she starts describing one part of
the book which i'm not going to mention
and she starts to cry
and i was like oh yeah you can't hide
this now girl i got you
i got you
so yes
tell me what you think
final spin it's available right now
order it
let me know what you think leadership
strategy and tactics field manual the
code the evaluation protocols which i
wrote with dave burke sarah armstrong
dismantles freedom field manual way of
the warrior kid one two three and four
mike and the dragons about faced by
hackworth which i wrote the forward to
extreme ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership which i wrote with my brother
leif babin
we also have a leadership consultancy
called echelon front we solve problems
through leadership leadership is the
solution
whatever problems you're having
leadership is the solution go to
echelonfront.com for details on that
and also we have an online training
platform we got a bunch of people
starting to join that right now which is
look we
have courses set up on there we have
daily drills you can do and we have live
sessions where i'm answering questions
the rest of the team is dave's there
lace there we're answering questions
we're doing that three times a week so
go to extremeownerships.com
if you want to get on board with that
and if you want to help service members
active and retired their families gold
star families
check out mark lee's mom mark lee's mom
incredible woman and she's got a charity
organization and it helps
it helps veterans and it helps service
members and families of all sorts
if you want to donate or you want to get
involved go to
americasmightywarriors.org
and if you want more of my
periphrastic pronouncements
or if you need more of echo's irrelevant
inquiries or you want any of dave's
ancillary editions
you can find us on the interwebs
on twitter on the gram and on facebook
dave is at david r burke echoes that
equatrolls and i am jocko willink and to
all the troops out there around the
world
and i'll at all those forgotten
barricades
thank you for the holding the line to
protect those of us here at home and to
our police law enforcement firefighters
paramedics emts dispatchers correctional
officers border patrol secret service
secret service and all first responders
thank you for holding the line
to keep us safe here on the home front
and everyone else out there let me just
remind you of that quote from francis
bacon
why should a man be in love with his
fetters though of gold
what's trapping you
what's controlling you what's
controlling your thoughts your ideas
your beliefs what's controlling your
mind
and the things that are controlling you
they might seem good they might be made
of gold
but they are enslaving you nonetheless
do not
let that happen cast off
those mental manacles and think
for your self
and until next time this is dave and
echo and jocko
out